This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus. And he realizes, or rather everybody else realizes, that there is a vast continent out there. And it is, of course, the Americas. So Anthropic knows the importance of questions. And it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution
本期节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。历史上的重大飞跃往往始于人们不愿触及的难题。是的，15世纪末就有一个经典的例子。当时那个难题具体是：大西洋以西究竟有什么？如你所知，找到这个答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布。他意识到，或者说其他人意识到，那里有一片广阔的大陆。当然，那就是美洲。所以Anthropic深知提问的重要性。这也是为什么Anthropic的创立初衷归根结底源于一个难题：我们如何确保人工智能革命
really goes well for ordinary people? So they asked over 100,000 people and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clodd.aI slash rest is history. Keep thinking. Mr. President, my company formed me of the explosion on our rig. On October 2nd.
真的能造福普通人？于是他们询问了超过10万人，得到的反馈不仅仅是恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症终有一天会被治愈吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。请访问clodd.ai/restishistory提出你的问题。保持思考。总统先生，我的公司通知我关于钻井平台爆炸的事。在10月2日。
Causing massive water displacement and triggering a tsunami. They all heap to blame all me. Tom Cruise is. Digger got us into this mess. And Digger's gonna dig us out. From the director of Birdman and the Revenant. What would happen if I stop doing?
导致了大规模的水体位移并引发了海啸。他们都把责任推给我。汤姆·克鲁斯是。挖掘者让我们陷入了这种困境。而挖掘者会把我们救出来。来自《鸟人》和《荒野猎人》的导演。如果我停止这样做会发生什么？
You starve. You freeze to death. That's what? With great power. Comes great deniability. I'm not the earth, Danny. Digger. See the trailer online. Only appears October 2nd.
你会饿死。你会冻死。那又怎样？能力越大。责任越大。我不是地球，丹尼。挖掘者。在线观看预告片。仅在10月2日上映。
This family is on the brink of Civil War. Mobland, the hit original series is now streaming on Paramount Plus. We are the Harrogans. Don't know than yet? And Google us. From the underworld of Guy Ritchie. Do you want to step up the ladder? I want combat dead. Starring Tom Hardy, Pierce Brosnan, and Helen Mirren.
这个家庭正处于内战的边缘。《莫布兰》，这部热门原创剧集现已在派拉蒙Plus上线。我们是哈罗根一家。还不认识我们？去谷歌搜一下。来自盖·里奇的地下世界。你想往上爬吗？我想战斗至死。由汤姆·哈迪、皮尔斯·布鲁斯南和海伦·米伦主演。
Do I have to do everything myself? You want to want? I'll give you more! Moblad. New season is now streaming on Paramount Plus. It is now 16 or 17 years since I saw the Queen of France, then the Dauphiness at Versailles, and surely never lighted on this orb, which she hardly seemed to touch a more delightful vision. I saw her just above the horizon, decorating and cheering the elevated sphere she just began to move in, glittering like the morning star, full of light. and splendor and joy. Oh, what a revolution. And what a heart must I have to contemplate without
难道什么事都要我亲力亲为吗？你想要更多？我会给你更多！《莫布兰》。新一季现已在派拉蒙Plus上线。距离我上次在凡尔赛宫见到法国王后，也就是当时的王储妃，已经过去16或17年了。我敢说，在这个星球上从未见过如此令人愉悦的景象，她似乎几乎没有触碰地面。我看到她就在地平线上方，装饰并点亮了她刚刚踏入的高层领域，像晨星一样闪耀，充满光芒、辉煌和喜悦。哦，这是一场怎样的革命。而我必须拥有一颗怎样的心，才能在不带
emotion, that elevation and that fall. Little did I dream when she added titles of veneration to those of enthusiastic, distant, respectful love that she should ever be obliged to carry the sharp antidote against disgrace concealed in that bosom. Little did I dream that I should have lived to see such disasters fallen upon her in a nation of gallant men, in a nation of men of honour and of cavaliers. I thought 10,000 swords must have leaped from their scabbards to avenge even a look that threatened her with insult. But the age of chivalry has gone. That of sophisters, economists and calculators has succeeded.
情感的情况下审视那样的升起与坠落。我做梦也没想到，当她将尊崇的头衔加在那些热情的、遥远的、恭敬的爱意之上时，她竟会被迫在胸中隐藏那对抗耻辱的尖锐解药。我做梦也没想到，我竟会活着看到这样的灾难降临在她身上，在一个由勇敢男士组成的国家，在一个由荣誉之士和骑士组成的国家。我以为会有1万把剑从剑鞘中跃出，去报复哪怕是一个威胁要侮辱她的眼神。但骑士时代已经一去不复返了。取而代之的是诡辩家、经济学家和计算者。
And the glory of Europe is extinguished forever. So that's one of the most celebrated pieces of prose ever written about the French Revolution. It was written by the Anglo-Irish politician and philosopher Edmund Burke, often seen as one of the godfathers of conservatism. Burk wrote those words in 1790. So very early on in the revolution, he was prompted by the tumultuous events really of 1789, the March on Versailles by a mob of market women and of revolutionary militants. The attack by night on the apartments of the Queen of France, which had sent her running barefoot to the bedchamber of her husband to seek sanctuary and the removal of the royal family to Paris, never to return to
欧洲的荣耀从此熄灭。这就是关于法国大革命最著名的散文片段之一。它由英裔爱尔兰政治家和哲学家埃德蒙·伯克撰写，他常被视为保守主义的教父之一。伯克在1790年写下了这些文字。因此，在大革命初期，他实际上是被1789年的动荡事件所触动，即由市场妇女和革命激进分子组成的暴徒对凡尔赛宫的进军。那场夜间对法国王后寝宫的袭击，迫使她赤脚奔向丈夫的卧室寻求庇护，并将王室成员带往巴黎，从此再未回到
Versailles. Tom, to Edmund Burke, as to so many like-minded people across Europe, this was practically sacrilegious, wasn't it? Yeah, because the French monarchy was the most splendid, the most magnificent in the whole of Europe. It provided a role model for every other royal family, and it stood at the apogee of an entire society that was founded on kind of loyalty and manners and notions of honor, which ultimately reached back a millennium and more to the very beginnings of the French monarchy amid the collapse of Roman Gaul. Its roots are that deep. And now to Burke and to people who read Burke and admired his sentiments, it seemed that everything that was most glorious about that monarchy and about those traditions were being reduced
凡尔赛。汤姆，对于埃德蒙·伯克以及欧洲各地许多志同道合的人来说，这简直是亵渎，不是吗？是的，因为法国君主制是整个欧洲最辉煌、最宏伟的。它为其他所有王室树立了榜样，并站在整个社会的巅峰，这个社会建立在忠诚、礼仪和荣誉观念之上，这些观念最终可以追溯到一千多年前，追溯到罗马高卢崩溃时期法国君主制的起源。它的根基就是那么深。而现在，对于伯克以及那些阅读伯克并钦佩他观点的人来说，似乎君主制和那些传统中最光荣的一切正在被简化
to kind of arid politicking about rights and money, which is essentially, the issues that were current in 1789 and 1790. But of course, for the monarchy and specifically for the king and queen of France, it gets a lot worse after 1790. I think for admirers of everything that royalism could be, the queen of France, the heroine of that passage, that very florid passage that you read, stood as a much more potent symbol of the French monarchy than the queen's dull and plodding husband Louis XVI, because the queen was, of course, Mary Antoinette, a figure who was famous across Europe for her glamour. She's a woman who was perpetually setting new trends with her clothes, her hairstyles, her whole way of life. She was on one hand bred into the height of luxury.
为关于权利和金钱的枯燥政治争论，这本质上是1789年和1790年的时事问题。但当然，对于君主制，特别是对于法国国王和王后来说，1790年之后情况变得更糟了。我认为，对于王权主义所能代表的一切的崇拜者来说，法国王后，也就是你读到的那段非常华丽的段落中的女主角，比王后那位迟钝且沉闷的丈夫路易十六更能代表法国君主制，因为王后当然是玛丽·安托瓦内特，一个以魅力闻名全欧洲的人物。她是一个不断用服装、发型和生活方式引领新潮流的女性。她一方面是在极度奢华中长大的。
She wasn't just the wife of the King of France, but the sister of the Emperor of Austria. but she was also a woman who had found herself stifled by the formalities of court life at Versailles. She had worn the most expensive jewels in Europe. And in fact, diamonds got her into quite a lot of trouble over the course of her time on the throne. But also famously in the Petitriano, her hideaway in the grounds of Versailles, she played at being a shepherdess. This was a woman who was incredibly mobile in her tastes, in her sense of fashion. She's always at the cutting edge of what is modish. And I think that she is viewed by historians of fashion as not just a representative figure
她不仅是法国国王的妻子，还是奥地利皇帝的妹妹。但她也是一个发现自己被凡尔赛宫廷生活形式所束缚的女性。她佩戴过欧洲最昂贵的珠宝。事实上，钻石在她统治期间给她惹了不少麻烦。但同样著名的是，在凡尔赛宫庭院里的私人小特里亚农宫，她扮演着牧羊女的角色。这是一个在品味和时尚感上极其多变的女性。她总是处于时尚的最前沿。我认为她被时尚历史学家视为不仅仅是一个代表人物
of the Anseigne, the regime that gets toppled in the French Revolution, but of ideals of fashion that will emerge in the 19th century and which are still very current in France today. So in that sense, she's a kind of trendsetter because she is a woman who, by always changing her dress, is establishing the idea of fashion as something that is never stable, that is constantly evolving. She is the face of the future as well as of the past. But arguably far more striking is Marianne's role in the propaganda of the 1780s that leads to the French Revolution, isn't it? Because she's loved by lots of people, but she's absolutely detested by others. Oh, by far more. I mean, I would say she's much more detested than loved. She becomes the personification of what people
法国大革命中被推翻的旧制度，而且是19世纪将要出现并至今在法国依然流行的时尚理想的代表。从这个意义上说，她是一个潮流引领者，因为她是一个通过不断更换服装，确立了时尚永远不稳定、不断演变这一理念的女性。她既是过去的脸孔，也是未来的脸孔。但可以说，玛丽安在1780年代导致法国大革命的宣传中的角色更为引人注目，不是吗？因为她被许多人爱戴，但也被其他人绝对憎恨。哦，被更多人憎恨。我的意思是，我会说她被憎恨的程度远超被爱戴。她成为了人们眼中
see as the injustices, the inequality of the ancient regime. So in the 1780s, as people are complaining about high taxes, as massive problems of the harvest, people running out of food and so on. The sort of stories of her extravagance are repeated in ever more lurid terms. And there's this sort of vein of scatological and pornographic criticism, Mariantoinette, which to a 21st century reader is actually pretty shocking. I mean, a lot of what is reported about Marie Antoinette in the 1780s and then into the 1790s is grotesque and I think one could say misogynistic fantasy. It is repeated by her enemies and believed by hundreds of thousands, that she is a woman who loves literally to bleed the people dry, that she is a kind of vampiress. She maintained at the expense of
旧制度不公正和不平等的化身。因此在1780年代，当人们抱怨高税收，当出现严重的收成问题，人们食物短缺等等时，关于她奢侈的故事以越来越耸人听闻的方式被重复。而且有一种针对玛丽·安托瓦内特的排泄物和色情批评，这对21世纪的读者来说实际上相当令人震惊。我的意思是，1780年代到1790年代关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的许多报道都是怪诞的，我认为可以说是一种厌女症的幻想。它被她的敌人重复，并被成千上万的人相信，她是一个字面上喜欢榨干人民鲜血的女人，她是一个吸血鬼。她以
the state, a legion of leeches who go out and bleed the poor dry. It is also said, as you know, that there's this pornographic element, that she is a kind of compulsive adulterous, that she's a nymphomaniac, that she's a lesbian, that she, practices incest with her own children and that she goes out murdering the children of paupers just for kicks. And all of this is believed. She comes to seem like a kind of monster from the pages of the Marquis de Sard. And so this has a knock-on effect on the way that her own children are seen because it is assumed that she's infected the royal bloodline with her own monstrous evil. There's a pamphlet in which she is made to cry out, a daughter of crime, I now give birth
国家的名义，供养了一群去榨干穷人鲜血的蚂蟥。正如你所知，还有一种说法是色情元素，说她是一个强迫性的通奸者，是一个性欲亢进者，是一个女同性恋者，她与自己的孩子乱伦，并且为了取乐而去谋杀穷人的孩子。而这一切都被相信了。她看起来就像萨德侯爵笔下的怪物。因此，这对她自己的孩子被看待的方式产生了连锁反应，因为人们认为她用自己怪诞的邪恶感染了王室血统。有一本小册子让她喊道：一个罪恶的女儿，我现在又生下了
to it in turn. And so there is the sense that. that her children, and particularly her sons, who are in the line to inherit the throne, that they are infected by this kind of taint of evil that Mariantoinette embodies. But while you have all the very, very aggressive, pornographic, misogynistic stuff about her, and it's hard not to feel sympathetic towards her, at the same time, the revolutionary sort of militants who in the early 1790s were, look, this woman is a bad person. There's no smoke without fire, right?
它。所以人们有一种感觉，她的孩子们，特别是那些有权继承王位的儿子们，被玛丽·安托瓦内特所体现的那种邪恶污点所感染。但是，当你听到所有关于她非常、非常激进、色情、厌女的内容时，很难不对她产生同情，与此同时，1790年代初的革命激进分子说，看，这个女人是个坏人。无风不起浪，对吧？
She has been very extravagant. she has been the personification of the inequality of the system. And crucially, when they accuse her of plotting against the revolution, conspiring against them, consorting with foreign powers against the French people, they're not wrong. So on the one hand, she is accused of being Madam Deficit, the woman who single-handedly has bankrupted France. I mean, this is very deeply believed. That's not true. But clearly, she has been very extravagant at a time of mass poverty. I mean, that's what Versailles is all about. It's kind of hardwired into the entire system. And as you say, she does conspire against the revolution. I mean, what would you expect? She's a queen. She hates it. And she experiences
她一直非常奢侈。她一直是制度不平等的化身。而且至关重要的是，当他们指控她策划反对革命、密谋反对他们、与外国势力勾结反对法国人民时，他们并没有错。所以一方面，她被指控为“赤字夫人”，那个单枪匹马让法国破产的女人。我的意思是，这被深信不疑。那不是真的。但显然，她在群众贫困时期一直非常奢侈。我的意思是，这就是凡尔赛宫的全部意义所在。它在某种程度上植根于整个系统中。正如你所说，她确实密谋反对革命。我的意思是，你期待什么呢？她是王后。她讨厌革命。而且她经历
the revolution as a kind of escalating process of humiliations and restrictions placed on her, placed on a lifestyle that previously had not had such restrictions. As we heard, she'd been brought from Versailles to Paris in 1789. They try and escape. They get to Varen. They are discovered and brought back. And then finally, in September 1792, the monarchy is formally abolished. And so she finds herself stripped of her very rank as queen. So it's not surprising that she should have conspired against the people and the revolutionary ideology that was inflicting this on her. So as you say, she did in the wars that the French Republic are fighting against foreign enemies. She did conspire with those foreign enemies. She did pass on sensitive military information to foreign agents. And she
革命是一个不断升级的羞辱和限制过程，这些限制被强加在她身上，强加在她以前没有这种限制的生活方式上。正如我们所听到的，她于1789年从凡尔赛被带到巴黎。他们试图逃跑。他们到达了瓦雷纳。他们被发现并被带回。最后，在1792年9月，君主制被正式废除。所以她发现自己被剥夺了王后的头衔。因此，她密谋反对人民和强加给她的革命意识形态并不令人惊讶。正如你所说，在法兰西共和国与外国敌人的战争中，她确实与那些外国敌人勾结。她确实向外国特工传递了敏感的军事信息。而她
did absolutely want to see the monarchy restored. She is complicit in what at the trial of Louis the 16th had been framed as treason. That is why Louis XVIth ends up going to the guillotine. And this happens on the 21st of January 1793. And when it happens, Marie Antoinette learns of the death of her husband by the sound of cannon fire ringing across Paris. And, Everything for her seems collapsed into ruin. So let's paint the picture now. So we are in January 1793. Where is she and what's her situation?
绝对想看到君主制复辟。她参与了在路易十六审判中被定性为叛国罪的行为。这就是路易十六最终走上断头台的原因。这发生在1793年1月21日。当这件事发生时，玛丽·安托瓦内特通过巴黎响起的炮声得知了她丈夫的死讯。而且，对她来说，一切似乎都陷入了毁灭。那么，让我们来描绘一下现在的画面。我们现在是在1793年1月。她在哪里，她的处境如何？
She is in the tower of a medieval fortress called the Temple and she had been kept there with her husband and with her immediate family with the execution of Louis XVIth, executed as a common criminal. This is the heir of Clovis and Louis the 14th. she now lacks a husband. So in a sense, she, I guess, feels that the responsibility for raising her children are now completely on her shoulders. She is firmly under the guard of people who never lose an opportunity to rub her nose in the loss of her royal status. When she had been moved into the temple, she had been brought royal bed sheets and obliged to pick out with her own
她被关在一座名为“圣殿”的中世纪堡垒的塔楼里，她和她的丈夫以及直系亲属被关在那里。随着路易十六作为普通罪犯被处决，这是克洛维和路易十四的继承人。她现在失去了丈夫。所以从某种意义上说，我想她觉得抚养孩子的责任现在完全落在了她的肩上。她被那些从不放过任何机会羞辱她失去王室地位的人严密看守。当她被转移到圣殿时，她被带去了王室床单，并被迫用自己的
needle the emblems of royalty on it, you know, the crown and so on. The guards refused to show her any respect. She is now obliged to show marks of respect to them. And all her titles have gone, all the markers of respect that had been a feature of her life, not just at Versailles, but growing up as a young girl back in Vienna. And her captors now refer to her in the wake of her husband's execution merely as Leverve Capet, the widow Capet, because Louis XVIth had become Louis Capet, cape being the name, the founding father of the kind of dynasty centuries before. And in fact, Louis He wasn't a cafe. He was a bourbon, but it's a kind of deliberate insult. So her world has completely imploded. Her husband is dead. Her baubles are gone. Everything that she took for granted
针线挑出上面的王室徽章，你知道，皇冠等等。守卫拒绝向她表示任何尊重。她现在被迫向他们表示敬意。她所有的头衔都消失了，所有曾经是她生活特征的尊重标志，不仅是在凡尔赛，还有她在维也纳长大的时候。她的俘虏现在在她丈夫被处决后，仅仅称她为“卡佩遗孀”，因为路易十六已经变成了路易·卡佩，卡佩是几个世纪前王朝创始人的名字。事实上，路易他不是卡佩。他是波旁，但这是一种故意的侮辱。所以她的世界完全崩溃了。她的丈夫死了。她的饰品没了。她认为理所当然的一切
has been ripped away from her. You would assume that she would sink into some form of depression or breakdown. I mean, that would be human nature, right? But she's more resilient than people expected. I actually think that even her enemies think that she has a quality of insolence, they would say, that means that she never gives up. Her admirers would say that she has kind of an indomitability. Over the months that follow the death of her husband, she makes clear that she is not surrendering to depression and a lack of purpose in almost every way that she can. Her focus now is her family. And there are four members of that family left to her in the tower with the death of Louis. So there is her husband's younger sister, Madame Elizabeth,
都被从她身边夺走了。你会认为她会陷入某种抑郁或崩溃。我的意思是，那将是人性，对吧？但她比人们预期的更有韧性。我实际上认为，即使是她的敌人也认为她有一种他们所说的傲慢，这意味着她从不放弃。她的崇拜者会说她有一种不屈不挠的精神。在她丈夫去世后的几个月里，她以几乎所有可能的方式表明她没有屈服于抑郁和失去目标。她现在的焦点是她的家庭。随着路易的去世，塔楼里还剩下四个家庭成员。所以有她丈夫的妹妹，伊丽莎白夫人，
as she's called, and her two children. And the eldest of these is a daughter, marry Therese Charlotte, and she's very grave. She's very shy. and her mother calls her Lax Seriairee's, the serious one. And she had turned 14 on the 19th of December, 1792. At the time her father was executed, that's her age. The younger of her two children, who she has with her, is the erstwhile dauphin, so the heir to the throne. And this is a little boy called Louis Chal.
正如她所称呼的那样，还有她的两个孩子。其中长女是玛丽·特蕾莎·夏洛特，她非常严肃。她非常害羞。她的母亲称她为“严肃的人”。她在1792年12月19日年满14岁。她父亲被处决时，她就是这个年纪。她身边的两个孩子中较小的一个是前王储，也就是王位继承人。这是一个叫路易·夏尔的小男孩。
And he had become the dauphin on the 4th of June 1789 with the death of his elder brother. I think perhaps it's forgotten that one of the reasons that Louis X-16, is distracted in the buildup to the fall of the Bastille is that he is a bereaved parent. He has lost his beloved elder son. Yeah, absolutely right. His parents were crushed. They were crushed by the loss of this child. And it took them out of the picture, the crucial points in the beginning of the revolution.
他在1789年6月4日随着他哥哥的去世成为了王储。我想也许人们忘记了，路易十六在巴士底狱陷落前夕分心的原因之一是他是一位丧子的父亲。他失去了他心爱的长子。是的，完全正确。他的父母崩溃了。他们被失去这个孩子的痛苦所压垮。这使他们在革命开始的关键时刻脱离了局势。
Louis-Shall had been four at the time. And so by the time his father is executed, he is seven and he turns eight on the 27th of March, 1793. And all things considered, he's quite a sunny child. I mean, you think of everything he's gone through, very sunny, very affectionate. He has blue eyes. He has blonde hair, very like his mother. And Marie Antoinette adores him. Well, she calls him her chou d'amour, her cabbage of love, which is kind of cutie pie, I guess you say it in English.
路易·夏尔当时四岁。所以当他父亲被处决时，他八岁，他在1793年3月27日满八岁。总而言之，他是一个相当阳光的孩子。我的意思是，你想到他所经历的一切，非常阳光，非常深情。他有蓝色的眼睛。他有金色的头发，非常像他的母亲。玛丽·安托瓦内特非常宠爱他。嗯，她称他为她的“爱之卷心菜”，这在英语里大概就是“可爱的小家伙”的意思。
You know, she adores him. But he is also, of course, in her opinion, much more than just her own, you know, her beloved little boy. He is Louis the 17th, the new king of France. And Marie Antoinette has treated as such the moment she heard those cannons ringing out over France to announce the death of her husband. So that evening, she had bowed before him, before her son, who at that point was only seven, and set him at the head of the table. He is now the king. And she had sought to replace her husband who had been teaching his son in the kind of the disciplines and the academic studies that he thought was. appropriate to a king. So Mariantoinette does her best to replace her husband and to teach her son,
你知道，她宠爱他。但当然，在她看来，他不仅仅是她自己的，你知道，她心爱的小男孩。他是路易十七，法国的新国王。玛丽·安托瓦内特从听到那些在法国上空响起宣布她丈夫死讯的炮声的那一刻起，就以此对待他。那天晚上，她在他面前，在当时只有七岁的儿子面前鞠躬，并让他坐在桌子首位。他现在是国王了。她试图取代她的丈夫，因为她丈夫一直在教导儿子他认为适合国王的纪律和学术研究。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特尽她所能取代她的丈夫来教导她的儿子，
maths, history, geography, all that kind of thing. And also to pray because he has to be raised as a Catholic, as the King of France. And so she teaches him to pray. Sadly, Louis-Shal confesses to her whenever I pray to God, it is always my father that appears to me. So he's obviously haunted, haunted by the death. That's very telling, isn't it? What about the guards? Because of course, the other people that they're basically sharing all their days with, the people who are in charge of looking after them. And the people who, as you've said, you know, they've made Mariannezzan unpick all the crowns with needle and thread and all that kind of thing. So they're not exactly, but definitely disposed towards these children. No, all of this is absolute anathema to them,
数学、历史、地理等等。还有祈祷，因为他必须作为法国国王被培养成天主教徒。所以她教他祈祷。可悲的是，路易·夏尔向她坦白：每当我向上帝祈祷时，出现的总是我的父亲。所以他显然被困扰，被死亡所困扰。这很能说明问题，不是吗？守卫们呢？因为当然，他们基本上每天都和这些人分享生活，那些负责照顾他们的人。以及正如你所说，他们让玛丽·安托瓦内特用针线拆掉所有的皇冠等等。所以他们并不完全倾向于这些孩子。不，所有这些对他们来说都是绝对的禁忌，
because to them, Louis-Shall is not Louis XIV, because the monarchy has been abolished. So they will call him Louis-Shal-Cape. Capet is seen as being his family name. So that's his official name now under the French Republic. But if they're feeling abusive, they will call him, you know, son of the tyrant or the wolf cub or worse things, as we will see. He's a very charming boy, by all accounts, and so some of them are charmed, and some of them do offer him kind of little kindnesses in the way that, you know, you do to a young child. I think the problem for Louis Chal is that this kind of war of wills that is constantly going on between Marie Antoinette and the Revolutionary Guards who have her under their control.
因为对他们来说，路易·夏尔不是路易十七，因为君主制已经被废除。所以他们会叫他路易·夏尔·卡佩。卡佩被视为他的姓氏。所以这是他在法兰西共和国下的正式名字。但如果他们感到虐待欲，他们会叫他，你知道，暴君之子或狼崽或更糟糕的东西，正如我们将看到的。据所有人的说法，他是一个非常有魅力的男孩，所以他们中的一些人被迷住了，一些人确实给了他一点小小的善意，就像你对待一个小孩子那样。我认为路易·夏尔的问题在于，玛丽·安托瓦内特和控制她的革命卫兵之间不断进行的这种意志之战，
means that he's always in the crosshairs of that conflict. And this conflict, it's taking place within their prism, but it also, it is echoed out in the broader world beyond the great walls of the temple. Because out there, among royalists in France, but also among the monarchies of Europe that are trying to throttle the French Republic in its cradle, all these implacable enemies of the revolution, they view Louis Charles Capet as Louis XIV, as the legitimate king of France. So to go through them, there's the foreign opponents. So we've talked about them, the Austrians, the Prussians, now of course the British. There are the emigres. So there are the princes, the aristocrats and whatnot, who went across to what's now Germany initially. They're a source of
意味着他总是处于那场冲突的交火点。而这场冲突，它发生在他们的棱镜之内，但它也在圣殿高墙之外的更广阔的世界中回响。因为在那里，在法国的保皇党中，也在试图将法兰西共和国扼杀在摇篮里的欧洲君主制国家中，所有这些革命的死敌，他们将路易·夏尔·卡佩视为路易十七，视为合法的法国国王。所以要通过他们，有外国对手。所以我们谈到了他们，奥地利人，普鲁士人，现在当然还有英国人。有流亡者。所以有那些最初前往现在德国的王子、贵族等等。他们是
enormous kind of provocation and angst for the revolutionaries. And now there are all these people in France itself. So of course, there are lots of latent royalists, but we talked last time. There is now a rebellion in the Vande, West Central France, south of Nantes, the royal and Catholic army, as it calls itself. People who wear these kind of white cockades, who are shouting Vive du Rois, long of the king, as a kind of battle cry and whatnot. And the king, and that is Louis XIV. Exactly. So for the revolutionaries, these are their implacable opponents. These are the people. They're an existential kind of arch enemy and the very person that is the focus for all these movements is right there in the
巨大的挑衅和焦虑的来源，对于革命者来说。现在法国本土也有了所有这些人。当然，有很多潜在的保皇党，但我们上次谈到了。现在在旺代，法国中西部，南特以南，有一场叛乱，即所谓的“王室和天主教军队”。人们戴着这种白色的帽徽，高喊“国王万岁”，作为一种战斗口号等等。而国王，那就是路易十七。完全正确。所以对于革命者来说，这些人是他们不可调和的对手。这些人。他们是一种生存意义上的死敌，而所有这些运动的焦点所在，就在
temple prison under the revolutionist noses. This little boy. And these fears of a kind of revanchist monarchy are turbocharged by what we've been emphasizing throughout this series is the key event in the spring of 1793, which really kind of lights the touch paper of the terror. And that is the defection of General de Morier. He is leading the French Revolutionary. and he turns coat and goes over to the Prussians and the Austrians. And his plan, very overtly, which he had tried to rally the French army to, wasn't just to overthrow the revolution, but to install Louis XIV as a constitutional monarch and essentially recalibrate the revolutionary regime as a kind of British-style constitutional monarchy. It's the failure of that
圣殿监狱里，在革命者的眼皮底下。这个小男孩。而这种对复辟君主制的恐惧被我们在这整个系列中强调的关键事件所加速，即1793年春天的关键事件，它真正点燃了恐怖的导火索。那就是迪穆里埃将军的叛逃。他领导着法国革命军，但他倒戈投向了普鲁士人和奥地利人。他的计划，非常公开地，他试图以此号召法国军队，不仅仅是推翻革命，而是要让路易十七成为君主立宪制的国王，并从本质上将革命政权重新调整为一种英式君主立宪制。正是那个项目的失败
project that leads him to defect to the Austrians. And so it's not surprising that when the news of that reaches Paris and bearing in mind the general mood of paranoia, the anxiety about conspiracies everywhere, that lots of patriots on the streets of Paris, the enraget, the people who are enraged by everything that's going wrong and starving and hungry and poor, that they should have detected in this conspiracy the malevolent puppet hand of Marie Antoinette. Clearly, Mary Antoinette is not in a position to be a mastermind in a conspiracy because she is shut up in this prison. And presumably the people who are actually running the revolution at this point, so let's take Robespierre. Robespierre, he must recognize that Marianne's
导致他投奔奥地利人。所以当这个消息传到巴黎时，考虑到普遍的偏执情绪，对到处都是阴谋的焦虑，巴黎街头的许多爱国者，那些被所有正在出错的事情激怒、挨饿、饥饿和贫穷的“狂人”，他们应该在这次阴谋中察觉到玛丽·安托瓦内特的邪恶傀儡之手，这并不奇怪。显然，玛丽·安托瓦内特并没有能力成为阴谋的主谋，因为她被关在这个监狱里。据推测，此时真正领导革命的人，比如罗伯斯庇尔。罗伯斯庇尔，他一定认识到玛丽·安托瓦内特
there's no need to kill her because, or to put her on trial or whatever it might be, because she's completely powerless. I mean, they can just basically keep her as a hostage. She's very useful to them as a hostage, I would have thought. Robs pier and Dantton both completely recognize this. So Robespierre, I mean, he's a massive conspiracy theorist. We talked about that in our previous episode. And he is definitely anti-monicist. He voted for the execution of Louis XVIth. But completely, he can recognize that Marie Antoinette is now, she's no threat to the revolution whatsoever. She is a broken, defeated woman. As we said in the last episode, the focus of Robespieres, anxieties and energies now are the Giron d'an. Those are the ones that he
没有必要杀她，或者审判她，或者其他什么，因为她完全无能为力。我的意思是，他们基本上可以把她当作人质。我想她作为人质对他们非常有用。罗伯斯庇尔和丹东都完全认识到了这一点。所以罗伯斯庇尔，我的意思是，他是一个巨大的阴谋论者。我们在上一集中谈到了这一点。他绝对是反君主制的。他投票赞成处决路易十六。但完全可以认识到，玛丽·安托瓦内特现在对革命没有任何威胁。她是一个破碎、失败的女人。正如我们在上一集中所说，罗伯斯庇尔现在焦虑和精力的焦点是吉伦特派。那些是他
sees as the arch conspirators. Those are the ones who need to be brought down. And so he doesn't really have any time for Marie Antoinette. It's kind of wasted energy. And Danton is by the summer of 1793, he is, I think, interested in the possibility of compromise. He seems to have had back channels to the Austrians. Rumors will develop that he's actually been in personal contact with Marie Antoinette. None of these rumors, I think, are true. But he's seen, I think, by the enragete as being soft on Marie Antoinette, definitely. Because out on the streets of Paris, as we've said, inflation is rampant, price of bread is going through the roof. There are lots of people who may not be as abreast of the kind of political and geopolitical dynamics of the situation as someone like
视为主要阴谋者的人。那些是需要被推翻的人。所以他真的没有时间理会玛丽·安托瓦内特。这是一种浪费精力的行为。而丹东到了1793年夏天，我认为，他对妥协的可能性感兴趣。他似乎与奥地利人有秘密渠道。谣言会发展成他实际上与玛丽·安托瓦内特有个人接触。我认为这些谣言都不是真的。但他被“狂人”视为对玛丽·安托瓦内特心慈手软，绝对是。因为在巴黎街头，正如我们所说，通货膨胀猖獗，面包价格飞涨。有很多人可能不像某些人那样了解局势的政治和地缘政治动态，比如
Ros Pierre or Dantan. But they feel things are going terribly, which they are. Marri Antoinette is the person who's been blamed for years and years and years for everything that goes wrong in France. And so they continue to do that. And there is one guy in particular who serves as their spokesman. And this is a journalist called Jacques Ebert. And he is a journalist. quite like Marat. He's a man who had recognized early on in the revolution the potential that the press offered to journalists who could make themselves the voice of the people. Ebert, like Marat, had turned his journalism into a kind of instrument of very violent political activism. So the difference between Ebert and Mara, I would say, is that, I mean, with Mara, it is pure
罗伯斯庇尔或丹东。但他们觉得事情变得非常糟糕，事实也确实如此。玛丽·安托瓦内特多年来一直被指责为法国发生的一切错误。所以他们继续这样做。有一个人特别充当了他们的代言人。这就是一个叫雅克·埃贝尔的记者。他是一名记者。很像马拉。他是一个在革命早期就认识到新闻业为那些能使自己成为人民代言人的记者提供的潜力的人。埃贝尔，像马拉一样，已经把他的新闻业变成了一种非常暴力的政治行动主义工具。所以埃贝尔和马拉之间的区别，我会说，我的意思是，对于马拉，那是纯粹的
vituperation, populist vituperation, incredibly aggressive, blood-soaked, all of this. Abert is similar, but more kind of demotic, more vulgar. He's speaking much more, I think. Marat strives for elevated language. I mean, not that it's terribly elevated, but Abert doesn't do that at all. He's trying to reflect, as he sees it, the mood on the streets, in the voice of the streets. So it's incredibly scatological, aggressive, pornographic. And, of course, that echoes the tone of all those pamphlets that had attacked Marantuanette in the 1780s.
谩骂，民粹主义的谩骂，极其激进，血腥，所有这些。埃贝尔类似，但更平民化，更粗俗。我认为他说话更多。马拉追求高雅的语言。我的意思是，并不是说它非常高雅，但埃贝尔根本不那样做。他试图反映他所看到的街头情绪，用街头的声音。所以它极其排泄物化、激进、色情。当然，这呼应了1780年代攻击玛丽·安托瓦内特的所有那些小册子的基调。
And I think crucially comic. I mean, he's funny. his abuse is enjoyable. He's taken on the persona of this guy, Per Duchenne, who is a foul-mouthed stovemaker from kind of theatre, and he's taken on his voice. And Ebert himself, predictably, is from a bourgeois background. I mean, all these kind of citizen journalists are, but it enables him to be as filthy and shocking as he likes, kind of gives him a licence.
而且我认为至关重要的是喜剧性。我的意思是，他很有趣。他的辱骂令人愉快。他采用了这个叫“杜申老爹”的人的形象，他是一个来自剧院的满口脏话的炉匠，他采用了他的声音。而埃贝尔本人，不出所料，来自资产阶级背景。我的意思是，所有这些所谓的公民记者都是，但这使他能够随心所欲地变得肮脏和令人震惊，给了他一种许可。
And the royal family have been his particular targets for years. So even back in the early months of the revolution, Abert had been shocking and delighting revolutionary sensibilities by abusing the royal family at a time where it was not the done thing to abuse the royal family. He's always having a crack at Louis XVI. He called him the Royal Cookhold, a fat pig. He's a man as timid as a mouse and as stupid as an ostrich. A bear will give it to the royal children.
而王室多年来一直是他的特别目标。所以即使在革命的最初几个月，埃贝尔也通过在不该辱骂王室的时候辱骂王室，震惊并取悦了革命情绪。他总是攻击路易十六。他称他为“皇家戴绿帽者”、“肥猪”。他是一个像老鼠一样胆小、像鸵鸟一样愚蠢的人。埃贝尔会攻击王室的孩子们。
So the things he says about Marit Torres, who is just a teenage girl, describes. her as being designed like the spiders of the French cape to suck the blood of slaves. Unsurprisingly, the real object of his venom had always been Mariannezzanette, the Austrian monster, the royal whore, just kind of endless stream of the Tuporation aimed at her. And he targets her really obsessively. And it's been estimated that one in seven of the articles that he published over the course of the revolution was about Mariannezzan. She's very much inside his head, I think. Yeah, and we mentioned the sexual content of this. The sexual content is uppermost, isn't it?
所以他说的关于玛丽·特蕾莎的事情，她只是一个十几岁的女孩，描述她被设计得像法国卡佩家族的蜘蛛一样去吸奴隶的血。不出所料，他愤怒的真正对象一直是玛丽·安托瓦内特，那个“奥地利怪物”、“皇家妓女”，只是针对她的一连串无休止的谩骂。他真的非常执着地针对她。据估计，他在革命期间发表的文章中，七分之一是关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的。我认为她真的占据了他的脑海。是的，我们提到了其中的色情内容。色情内容是首要的，不是吗？
So this is pure kind of pornographic misogyny. What it does is it turns her from a flesh and blood human being that people might feel sorry for to a kind of creature of nightmares almost. It completely dehumanizes her. And it also serves to keep her in the public eye, even once she sees to be queen, being bottled up behind these kind of eight massive doors in her prison. It keeps her in the public eye as someone who is so monstrous and cunning and fiendish. that of course she is the person who is running this mass conspiracy.
所以这是一种纯粹的色情厌女症。它所做的是将她从一个人们可能会同情的有血有肉的人变成了一种几乎是噩梦中的生物。它完全非人化了她。而且它还有助于让她保持在公众视野中，即使在她不再是王后之后，被关在监狱里的八扇巨大门后。它让她作为一个人保持在公众视野中，她是如此怪诞、狡猾和邪恶，以至于她当然是那个正在策划这场大规模阴谋的人。
And so in the spring of 1793, when Dumorriere goes over to the Austrians, and the French Republic seems on the verge of collapse, Abert is all about Marianne, he's saying she's the person to blame, she is the person who we need to dispatch. He says liberty is hanging by only a hair. So Marianneux, of course, always famous for her glamorous hairstyles. At this point, however, the Committee of Public Safety don't take any notice of this. They've got much bigger fish to fry.
所以1793年春天，当迪穆里埃投奔奥地利人，法兰西共和国似乎濒临崩溃时，埃贝尔完全关注玛丽·安托瓦内特，他说她是该受责备的人，她是我们需要除掉的人。他说自由只悬于一线。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特，当然，一直以她迷人的发型而闻名。然而，此时，救国委员会并没有注意到这一点。他们有更重要的事情要处理。
Exactly. I mean, they're facing a massive crisis on the frontiers, national economic emergency. I mean, they've got better things to worry about than one woman locked up in prison, pretty safely in prison. Yes, so they're not particularly anxious about Mary Antoinette. She's not the focus of their attention. But having said that, they don't completely ignore the warnings that Abert and the kind of, you know, his fellow radicals are giving. You know, as we've said, that there are royal conspiracies afoot. You know, royalism has led to kind of a, you know, mass counter.
完全正确。我的意思是，他们正面临边境的巨大危机，国家经济紧急状态。我的意思是，他们有比一个关在监狱里的女人更重要的事情要担心，在监狱里相当安全。是的，所以他们对玛丽·安托瓦内特并不是特别焦虑。她不是他们关注的焦点。但话虽如此，他们并没有完全忽视埃贝尔和他的激进同僚们发出的警告。你知道，正如我们所说，王室阴谋正在酝酿。你知道，保皇主义导致了一种大规模的反
a revolution. And so the issue of what to do with the surviving members of what had once been the royal family is an issue. I mean, it's not a priority, but it is a problem that does need solving. As we pass into the summer of 1793, various measures do start to be taken. So in April, the convention orders a kind of mass police sweep against possible supporters of the monarchy and particularly aristocracy. And obviously, members of the House of Bourbon, the ex-royal family, are the key people who the revolutionary authorities
革命。所以如何处理曾经是王室成员的幸存者是一个问题。我的意思是，这不是优先事项，但这是一个确实需要解决的问题。随着我们进入1793年夏天，各种措施确实开始被采取。所以4月，国民公会下令对可能的君主制支持者，特别是贵族进行大规模的警察搜查。显然，波旁家族的成员，前王室成员，是革命当局
feel need to be apprehended. And the most prominent of these is Philippe Egalite, the Duke of O'Leon, as he had been, the cousin of Louis XVI, and who, as a deputy in the convention, had voted for his cousin to be executed. I think we agreed, didn't we? He's one of the worst people who's ever lived.
认为需要逮捕的关键人物。其中最突出的是菲利普·平等，也就是奥尔良公爵，路易十六的堂兄，作为国民公会的代表，他投票赞成处决他的堂兄。我想我们同意了，不是吗？他是史上最糟糕的人之一。
Isn't that right? Didn't we with Boise Douglas? I mean, he's just a terrible person, Philippe Egalite. No? Well, I think we've described him as the Prince Harry of the Revolution. Yeah, I mean, yeah, case closed. And the problem for him, there's actually no evidence at all that he was involved in any counter-revolutionary conspiracies. I think he backed the revolution.
不是吗？我们和博伊斯·道格拉斯不是这样说的吗？我的意思是，他只是一个可怕的人，菲利普·平等。不是吗？嗯，我想我们把他描述为革命时期的哈里王子。是的，我的意思是，是的，结案了。对他来说的问题是，实际上没有任何证据表明他参与了任何反革命阴谋。我认为他支持革命。
He was all in favour of equality. I think he believed it. The problem for him is, as you said in the first episode, the Wendy Morier went over to the Austrians. He took with him, Philippe Agallet's second son, the girl. who in due course is going to become King Louis Philippe. And that means that from this point on, Philippe Agileile is a man. So he gets arrested in Marseille, gets in prison there, and then in due course he gets brought to Paris.
他完全赞成平等。我想他相信这一点。对他来说的问题是，正如你在第一集中所说，当迪穆里埃投奔奥地利人时。他带走了菲利普·平等的次子，那个后来成为路易·菲利普国王的人。这意味着从这一点开始，菲利普·平等是一个人。所以他在马赛被捕，被关在那里，然后最终被带到巴黎。
So things aren't looking good for him. Meanwhile, what about Marie Antoinette herself? So three months after those series of arrests, the arrest of Philippe Pallet and other members of the elite aristocracy, guards come to her. And it's the night of the 3rd of July. And this is the moment that Marie Antoinette has been good. dreading from the moment that she and her family were brought to this terrible prison because she is separated from her beloved son. So the guards turn up at 10 o'clock in the evening while
所以情况对他来说看起来不太好。与此同时，玛丽·安托瓦内特本人呢？所以在那一系列逮捕，逮捕菲利普·平等和其他精英贵族三个月后，守卫来到她身边。那是7月3日晚上。这是玛丽·安托瓦内特从她和家人被带到这个可怕监狱的那一刻起就一直担心的时刻，因为她与她心爱的儿子分开了。所以守卫在晚上10点出现，当时
Marie Antoinette is sewing by candlelight and her son is curled up asleep next to her. And Marianne Trenet immediately realizes what is happening. And so she stands over her son and blocks the access of the guards to Louis Jard. And Marie Terez, who in due course, spoiler alert, is going to be exiled by the revolutionaries. So she gets expelled from France in 1795, and this enables her to write up reminiscences of what happened, which are crucial evidence for what's going on. And Marie Therese wrote later that her mother told them they would have to kill her before they could tear her child from her. And the standoff continues for an hour. And only when the guards say, look, let him go, or we are going to kill you and we're going to kill him and we're going to
玛丽·安托瓦内特正在烛光下缝纫，她的儿子蜷缩在她身边睡着了。玛丽·安托瓦内特立刻意识到发生了什么。于是她站在儿子身边，挡住了守卫接近路易·夏尔的通道。玛丽·特蕾莎，后来，剧透警告，将被革命者流放。所以她在1795年被驱逐出法国，这使她能够写下所发生事情的回忆录，这是正在发生的事情的关键证据。玛丽·特蕾莎后来写道，她的母亲告诉他们，他们必须先杀了她，才能把她的孩子从她身边夺走。对峙持续了一个小时。只有当守卫说，看，让他走，否则我们要杀了你，我们要杀了他，我们要
kill your daughter as well. Only then does Mariantoinette finally give in. And again, to quote Marie Torres, bathing him with her tears and overwhelmed with a sense of foreboding that she would never see him again. She gave him into the hands of the guards. And the guards then lead the little boy away. And the door is slammed in his mother's face. And Mariantoinette can hear him being led down a spiral staircase from the room directly below them, which had been Louis's room the day that he had been executed. That was the room that Louis had been taken to the guillotine from. And And the little boy knows this entirely. He is locked up in that room.
还要杀了你的女儿。只有这样，玛丽·安托瓦内特才最终屈服。正如玛丽·托雷斯所言，她泪流满面，心中充满了再也见不到儿子的不祥预感。她把他交到了守卫手中。守卫随后把小男孩带走了。门在母亲面前重重地关上了。玛丽·安托瓦内特能听到他被带下螺旋楼梯，穿过他们正下方的房间，那正是路易被处决那天所在的房间。那是路易被带去断头台的房间。小男孩完全明白这一点。他被锁在了那个房间里。
And Marie Antoinette can hear his sobbing rising up through the floorboards. For any parents, just an absolutely horrendous, horrendous experience. I mean, you can't imagine anything worse. Terrible. And all that she knows about his fate is that she can hear him weeping. She knows nothing else. She has no idea what is happening to him. It is a complete mystery to her.
玛丽·安托瓦内特能听到他的啜泣声穿过地板传上来。对于任何父母来说，这绝对是一次极其可怕、极其痛苦的经历。我的意思是，你无法想象还有比这更糟糕的事情了。太可怕了。她对他命运所知的一切，就是能听到他的哭泣声。她一无所知。她根本不知道他正在经历什么。这对她来说完全是个谜。
That's what's happening with the royal family. But meanwhile, in the convention, so effectively the government of France, the deputies there are preparing a much more public assault on the legacy of monarchy. And on the 31st of July, 1793, a lawyer named Bertrand Barre stands up in the National Convention. And we have already met him because he is the guy who in due course on the 5th of September will proclaim that terror is. the order of the day. And we didn't really say who he was then. So just a bit of detail on him. He's a man with very formidable reputation. He'd been the first man to be elected to the Committee of Public Safety. So that's a kind of measure of the reputation that he has. And he's the chief spokesman of the committee in the convention. He'd been a lawyer, very celebrated for
这就是王室正在发生的事情。但与此同时，在国民公会，也就是法国的实际政府中，那里的代表们正准备对君主制的遗产发动更公开的攻击。1793年7月31日，一位名叫贝特朗·巴雷尔的律师在国民公会站了起来。我们已经见过他了，因为他就是那个在9月5日宣布“恐怖是当务之急”的人。当时我们并没有详细介绍他是谁。所以，关于他的一些细节：他是一个声誉卓著的人。他是第一个被选入救国委员会的人。这足以衡量他的声望。他是委员会在国民公会的主要发言人。他曾是一名律师，以
his eloquence. Robert Palmer in his classic book on the Committee of Public Safety 12, who ruled gives a fabulous character sketch of him. Barre could throw a spell of words over any usual topic, a battle, a conspiracy, a guillotining, a statistical report, a democratic idea, always fluent, always forceful, sometimes soberly expository, sometimes passionately excited. And this is a guy who, he'd been on the kind of the outer margins of the aristocracy when the revolution began. So he's adapted himself very fluently and, successfully to the new order. He's a very fluent, very plausible man, but also in the opinion of his detractors, you know, a complete opportunist. And so in other words, this makes him the most
他的口才而闻名。罗伯特·帕尔默在他关于救国委员会的经典著作《十二人统治》中，对他进行了精彩的人物素描。巴雷尔能用言语给任何常见话题施加魔力，无论是战争、阴谋、断头台处决、统计报告还是民主思想，他总是口若悬河、强而有力，有时冷静阐述，有时充满激情。他是一个在革命开始时处于贵族阶层边缘的人。所以他非常灵活且成功地适应了新秩序。他是一个非常健谈、非常有说服力的人，但在他的批评者看来，他是一个彻头彻尾的机会主义者。换句话说，这使他成为
reliable weather vein in the whole the revolution. If you want to know the way the wind is turning, see which way Barre is turning is basically the idea. It's a brilliant politician. He basically works out where the centre ground is, where the momentum is heading, and he makes sure he's always there. He is the person who serves in your cabinet, you know, if in contemporary politics for kind of 10 years, he's reliable, he's a safe pair of hands, he's always there. And he miraculously always agrees with what the Prime Minister of the day believes. I mean, that's basically what he is. And as Prime Minister's rise and fall, he's a kind of constant. And what he is pointing to in the summer of 1793 is the fact that it is time to eradicate from France every last
整个革命中最可靠的风向标。如果你想知道风向如何转变，看看巴雷尔转向哪里就知道了，基本就是这个意思。他是一位杰出的政治家。他基本上能算出中间立场在哪里，势头正朝哪个方向发展，并确保自己始终站在那里。在当代政治中，如果你在内阁中任职十年，他就是那种可靠、稳重、始终如一的人。而且他奇迹般地总是同意当时首相的观点。我的意思是，他基本上就是这样的人。随着首相们的起起落落，他成了一种恒量。他在1793年夏天所指出的事实是，现在是时候从法国彻底根除
trace of the monarchy to remove all the symbols that still adorn the cities and the cathedrals and so on, they've all got to go. You know, France has to be a country that is recognizably revolutionary and Republican in its outward show. And this is a process that had already begun. So squares or streets that had previously been named after kings, they've been given new names. The statues of kings have been toppled. And above all, what he is proposing is the systematic elimination of every last trace of monarchy from the basilica that is, and always has been, its great shrine. And this is the basilica of Saint-Denie, which stands just to the north of Paris. And ever since Frankish times, it has been the royal necropolis. It had been massively expanded in the 12th century. Essentially,
君主制的每一丝痕迹，移除所有装饰在城市、大教堂等地方的象征，它们都必须消失。法国必须成为一个在外观上显而易见的革命和共和国家。这个过程已经开始了。那些以前以国王命名的广场或街道，都被赋予了新的名字。国王的雕像被推倒了。最重要的是，他提议系统性地消除圣但尼大教堂中君主制的最后痕迹，那里一直以来都是君主制的伟大圣地。圣但尼大教堂位于巴黎北部。自法兰克时代以来，它一直是皇家墓地。它在12世纪进行了大规模扩建。本质上，
it's the first great masterpiece of the Gothic style. And it is essentially the Westminster Abbey of France. This is where kings for generation to generation after generation have been very Their monuments are everywhere. And the convention says, yeah, this is a brilliant idea. Let's crack on with this. And on the first of August 1793, they officially approve Barre's proposal. Six days later, a crowd of workmen and soldiers in red liberty caps turn up outside San Deney. They break into the basilica and they begin the work of demolition.
它是哥特式风格的第一部伟大杰作。它本质上是法国的威斯敏斯特教堂。这是国王们一代又一代被埋葬的地方。他们的纪念碑随处可见。国民公会说，是的，这是一个绝妙的主意。让我们开始吧。1793年8月1日，他们正式批准了巴雷尔的提议。六天后，一群戴着红色自由帽的工人和士兵出现在圣但尼大教堂外。他们闯入大教堂，开始了拆除工作。
And they begin at the beginning. They go for the first king to be buried there, who's a guy called Dagabert I. He'd founded the abbey. He'd been buried there back in 638, so long ago. And then basically they worked their way very systematically through what's effectively 1100 years of French royal history. And there are so many kings, there are so many monuments that it's not until October that the great task is completed.
他们从头开始。他们首先针对的是埋葬在那里的第一位国王，一个叫达戈贝尔一世的人。他建立了这座修道院。他早在638年就被埋葬在那里，那是很久以前的事了。然后，他们基本上非常系统地处理了长达1100年的法国皇室历史。国王太多了，纪念碑也太多了，直到十月这项伟大的任务才完成。
It's an incredible, incredible operation of destruction, isn't it? Absolutely massive. Every monument is smashed, every sarcophagus, every kind of casket containing hearts or whatever. And over 100 royal corpses are exhumed. The workmen dig two great trenches beside what had been the chapel of the Valois, so the medieval kings who had fought Edward III and then read the myth and so on. That chapel has been demolished. And now there are these two great trenches and all the bodies of the kings and queens get dumped into them. And the older corpses have obviously, you know, they've crumbled away. So Barre had described them as the impure ashes of tyrants. And these impure ashes,
这是一场令人难以置信的破坏行动，不是吗？规模极其宏大。每一座纪念碑都被砸碎，每一个石棺，每一个装有心脏或其他东西的棺材。超过100具皇家尸体被挖掘出来。工人们在瓦卢瓦礼拜堂旁边挖了两个大坑，也就是那些曾与爱德华三世作战的中世纪国王们埋葬的地方。那个礼拜堂已经被拆除了。现在有了这两个大坑，所有的国王和王后的尸体都被扔了进去。较古老的尸体显然已经风化了。所以巴雷尔称它们为“暴君的不纯灰烬”。而这些不纯的灰烬，
I mean, it's usually to dispose of them. But the more recent ones, I mean, that's a much more unpleasant job, because particularly the Bourbonnes, the dynasty to which Louis XVIth had belonged, they've been buried a few decades before, a few centuries before. They are still in a condition of putrefaction, and the stench is absolutely revolting once they start digging them up. It's an absolutely hideous scene. The workmen have to burn vinegar and gunpowder to combat the nauseous vapors
我的意思是，处理它们通常很容易。但最近的那些，那是一项更令人不快的工作，因为特别是波旁王朝，也就是路易十六所属的王朝，他们是几十年前、几个世纪前才被埋葬的。他们仍处于腐烂状态，一旦开始挖掘，恶臭简直令人作呕。这是一个极其可怕的场景。工人们不得不燃烧醋和火药来对抗从这些被亵渎的坟墓中升起的恶臭气体。
that are rising up from these desecrated tombs. But eventually the work is done. Every last trace of France's royal past is erased from San Deney. With this, the basilica can be put to a more practical and purposeful use. And so it serves as a warehouse for grain and for flour. I have the irony. The one thing that the French didn't have enough of in the 1780s, and they blame the monarchy for not giving them.
但最终工作完成了。法国皇室过去的每一丝痕迹都从圣但尼被抹去了。有了这个，大教堂就可以用于更实际和更有目的的用途。于是它被用作谷物和面粉的仓库。我感受到了其中的讽刺。这是18世纪80年代法国人最缺乏的东西，他们还责怪君主制没有提供给他们。
And now that's why the basilica is storing. All right. They may have taken out the symbols, but there are some living people remaining, of course. There are the counter-revolutioners in the Vande, who are still proclaiming their loyalty to Louis XIV, as they call him. And of course, in the temple, there are those members of France's royal family, still there are standing, living affront to the ideals of the new republic. We'll find out what happens to them, the tragic story of Marion Trenet and her son after the break. This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps, many of them started as hard questions that people didn't want asked.
现在这就是大教堂储存的东西。好吧。他们可能已经移除了象征，但当然还有一些活着的人。在旺代有反革命分子，他们仍在宣誓效忠他们所称的路易十七。当然，在圣殿塔里，还有法国王室的成员，他们依然是新共和国理想的活生生的冒犯。休息后，我们将了解玛丽·安托瓦内特和她儿子的悲惨故事。本集由Anthropic赞助，这是Claude背后的团队。现在，历史上最大的飞跃，其中许多始于人们不想问的难题。
Yeah, there's a classic example of that, Tom, at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus, That's great pioneering voyage of discovery, and it is, of course, the Americas. So, you know, Anthropic knows the importance of questions, and it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution really goes well for ordinary people? Anthropic asked 100,000 people.
是的，汤姆，15世纪末有一个经典的例子。那个难题特别在于，大西洋西岸之外有什么？正如你所知，找到那个问题答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布，那次伟大的开拓性发现之旅，当然，就是美洲。所以，Anthropic知道问题的重要性，这就是为什么Anthropic建立在一个最重要的难题之上。我们如何确保人工智能革命真正为普通人带来好处？Anthropic询问了10万人。
And what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? Can kids have a better future? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clod.AI slash rest is history. And keep thinking. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers, The Rest is Science.
得到的反馈不仅仅是恐惧。还有希望。人们想知道，癌症会被治愈吗？孩子们能有更好的未来吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。在clod.AI/rest is history提出你的问题。并继续思考。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers《历史的其余部分》的迈克尔和汉娜。
This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. Think of some things that glow. Okay, fireflies, glow sticks, the northern lights. They're very cool. But what if we could replicate that glow inside our bodies and what if doing so could help us save lives? Because Cancer Research's UK scientists, they're investigating whether a special fluorescent dye that sticks to prostate cancer cells could tackle an ongoing challenge in the operating room, removing every single trace of cancer. Because when cancer cells are glowing and easy to spot, surgeons can precisely remove them, leaving healthy cells untouched, meaning there's less chance of the cancer returning and fewer nasty side effects.
本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。想想一些会发光的东西。好吧，萤火虫、荧光棒、北极光。它们非常酷。但如果我们能在体内复制这种光芒，如果这样做能帮助我们拯救生命呢？因为英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在研究一种能粘附在前列腺癌细胞上的特殊荧光染料，是否能解决手术室中一个持续存在的挑战：清除每一丝癌细胞。因为当癌细胞发光且容易被发现时，外科医生可以精确地切除它们，使健康细胞不受影响，这意味着癌症复发的几率更小，副作用也更少。
Cancer Research UK's vision is a world where everybody lives longer. better lives free from the fear of cancer, with breakthroughs like this leading to kinder, more effective treatments. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit canterresearchuk.org slash rest is science. Welcome back to The Rest is History. So, the Republican government in Paris is locked in a life or death struggle against what it sees as the forces of royalism and reaction and counter-revolution. And as we have heard, the National Convention have stripped from the Great Basilica and Sandinie every last trace of monarchical history.
英国癌症研究中心的愿景是一个每个人都能活得更长、更好，免受癌症恐惧的世界，像这样的突破带来了更温和、更有效的治疗方法。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问cancerresearchuk.org/rest is science。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。所以，巴黎的共和政府正陷入一场生死存亡的斗争，对抗它所认为的保皇主义、反动和反革命势力。正如我们所听到的，国民公会已经从圣但尼大教堂剥离了君主制历史的每一丝痕迹。
And that same day that they voted the 1st of August, they moved Mariannezzan from her prison in the temple late at night for the first time. She's been there for a year, hasn't she? And there's an ominous moment as they take her out. She bangs her head on the lintel and one of them says, are you hurt? And she says, nothing can hurt me now. There's a sort of sense that basically she's fallen as low as it's possible to fall. But of course, there's further to go.
就在他们投票的同一天，即8月1日，他们深夜第一次将玛丽·安托瓦内特从圣殿塔的监狱中转移出来。她在那里待了一年，不是吗？当他们带她出去时，有一个不祥的时刻。她撞到了门楣，其中一个人说，你受伤了吗？她说，现在没有什么能伤害我了。有一种感觉，基本上她已经跌到了可能跌到的最低点。但当然，还有更远的路要走。
Oh, there is. There is. So she is being transferred to central Paris. So she heads westwards across the capital and then over the seine and she's brought on to the Eau de la Cite where Notre Dame stands. And it's here in the early hours of 2nd of August, 1793, that she arrives in her new home, which is the conciergerie. And we mentioned it briefly, but just to give a bit more detail about it, this had served as a royal prison since the 14th century. And it occupies the kind of the lower level of the building complex, the Palais de Justice, that also houses the revolutionary tribunal.
哦，有的。确实有。所以她被转移到巴黎市中心。她向西穿过首都，然后越过塞纳河，被带到了巴黎圣母院所在的西岱岛。就在1793年8月2日凌晨，她抵达了她的新家，即古监狱。我们简要提到了它，但为了提供更多细节，自14世纪以来，它一直作为皇家监狱使用。它占据了司法宫建筑群的下层，那里也设有革命法庭。
Yeah. So that had been set up back in the early hours of the 11th of March at the urgent. of d'Anton to try cases without appeal. And the more prisoners that there are for the revolutionary tribunal to try, so the more the conciergerie comes to serve as the kind of the central holding pen for the terror. And the widow Capet, Marie Antoinette, is one of these prisoners, and she is processed in the conciergerie as a common criminal. She's not being arraigned as a former queen. She's just a criminal like anyone else. She's kept in a small cell on the ground floor, and the description of it,
是的。所以它是在3月11日凌晨在丹东的敦促下建立的，旨在审理案件且不得上诉。革命法庭审理的囚犯越多，古监狱就越成为恐怖时期的中心拘留所。卡佩遗孀玛丽·安托瓦内特就是这些囚犯之一，她在古监狱被当作普通罪犯处理。她不是作为前王后被传讯的。她只是像其他人一样的罪犯。她被关在底层的一个小牢房里，对它的描述是，
it's small, damp and feted without a stove or fireplace. There's also no window. And actually one way in which Mariantoinette is an exceptional prisoner is that she's not allowed any exercise. All the other prisons are allowed out to see the sky,
它又小、又潮湿、又恶臭，没有炉子或壁炉。也没有窗户。事实上，玛丽·安托瓦内特作为一个特殊囚犯的一个方面是，她不允许进行任何锻炼。所有其他监狱的囚犯都被允许出去看天空，
to see the blue sky above them and to stretch their legs. Mariannezzanette is not. She's kept in her cell permanently. And the cell is very bare. There's a palette on which she can sleep. There's a chair and a table and there's a bucket for her ablutions.
看头顶的蓝天并伸展双腿。玛丽·安托瓦内特则不行。她被永久地关在牢房里。牢房非常空旷。有一张她可以睡觉的草垫。有一把椅子和一张桌子，还有一个用于洗漱的桶。
There is a small. screen that runs halfway across the room, only barely five feet high, so very easy for people to look over it. And on the other side of the screen from Marie Antoinette are two guards who are constantly there. She's never without these two guards. And they sit there smoking, drinking, playing cards, you know, abusing her, whatever. So she is never alone. And on top of that, there is a grill in her prison door. And so for a fee, visitors can go and open that grill and peer inside and gorp at the Austrian whore. So, you know, one of the great spectacles of Revolutionary France, kind of see this, this monster reduced to the level, basically, of an
房间中间有一个小屏风，只有五英尺高，所以人们很容易越过它看过去。在玛丽·安托瓦内特屏风的另一边是两名守卫，他们始终在那里。她从不离开这两名守卫。他们坐在那里抽烟、喝酒、打牌，你知道，虐待她，等等。所以她从不孤单。最重要的是，她的牢房门上有一个格栅。所以只要付钱，游客就可以去打开那个格栅，往里窥视，盯着这个“奥地利妓女”。所以，你知道，这是革命法国的伟大奇观之一，看着这个怪物被降级到基本上是
animal. And there are a lot of people who are keen to do that, aren't there? Yeah, because even in the squalid depths of her downfall, Marie Antoinette remains complete box office. You know, she's still what she, she's been for decades, the most famous woman in France, by far. And she is the one prisoner whom royalists dream of springing. You know, there are a are various kind of chevalier who make the attempt while she's in the concierge to zero effect. But she remains the queen of their hearts. And of course, she's the one prisoner whom true patriots, true revolutionaries want to see, brought to the guillotine. So as at Versailles, so now in the depths of the terror. You know, she is still a star. However, I think for the
动物的水平。而且有很多人热衷于这样做，不是吗？是的，因为即使在她堕落的肮脏深渊中，玛丽·安托瓦内特仍然是票房保证。你知道，她仍然是几十年来法国最著名的女性，遥遥领先。她是保皇党梦想营救的唯一囚犯。你知道，在她在古监狱期间，有各种各样的骑士试图这样做，但毫无效果。但她仍然是他们心中的女王。当然，她是真正的爱国者、真正的革命者想要看到被送上断头台的唯一囚犯。所以就像在凡尔赛一样，现在在恐怖的深渊中。你知道，她仍然是一位明星。然而，我认为对于
Committee for Public Safety, she's still unimportant. She's a distraction. The head of the Hydra that they want to cut off is not Mariantoinette. It's the Catholic and royal army in the Vonde. That is the real royalist monster that they are anxious to see destroyed. And this is because all spring, all summer, the royalist army in the Vonday has been on an absolute role. So we heard in our previous episode how this had helped to prompt the great Leveille en masse of the 23rd of August, this unprecedented introduction of mass conscription in France, the first great mass conscription of the modern age, and which in the long run will provide the revolution with manpower beyond the dreams of the Ancien regime. I mean, kind of within a year, double the size of the
救国委员会来说，她仍然不重要。她是一个干扰。他们想要砍掉的九头蛇的头不是玛丽·安托瓦内特。而是旺代的天主教和皇家军队。那是他们急于看到被摧毁的真正的保皇党怪物。这是因为整个春天、整个夏天，旺代的保皇党军队一直处于绝对的优势。所以我们在上一集中听到，这如何帮助促成了8月23日的伟大全民动员，这是法国前所未有的群众征兵，是现代第一次伟大的群众征兵，从长远来看，它将为革命提供超出旧制度梦想的人力。我的意思是，在一年之内，规模翻了一番，
army that Louis XIV had commanded. 700,000 men in uniform, extraordinary. Fast, vast force. But in the immediate term, it's still proving inadequate to suppress this counter-revolutionary uprising in Navonde. And so accordingly, as well as a mobilisation for total war, the Committee for Public Safety mandate an outright policy of extermination. They say that forests have to be cut down, that all crops have to be burned, that livestock have to be seized, that the rebels basically have to be starved into submission, and that the rebels themselves, if they're found, have to be hunted down like beasts. They have to be exterminated without mercy as though they are, you know, wolves, Berman, to be eradicated completely. So this is the policy
超过了路易十四指挥的军队。70万名穿制服的士兵，非同寻常。庞大的力量。但在短期内，它仍然不足以镇压旺代的反革命起义。因此，除了全面战争动员外，救国委员会还授权了一项彻底的灭绝政策。他们说森林必须被砍伐，所有庄稼必须被烧毁，牲畜必须被没收，叛军基本上必须被饿到投降，如果发现叛军，必须像野兽一样被追捕。他们必须被毫不留情地消灭，就像他们是狼、害虫一样，必须被彻底根除。所以这就是
that's going on in the west of France, far from Paris, but to the mass of Saint-Colot in the slums of Paris, the enrages, the poor who are starving, hungry, their suspicions, their hatreds, they're being amplified by Jacques Herbert, people like that, these kind of incendiary journalists. Even this policy of extermination is not felt to be enough. If you're an enraget in Paris, essentially what is happening in the Vonde, it's far away. You don't really have a handle on it. You've never been there. You don't really know. know what's going on. What you do know is that there are members of the royal family who are still alive and there are ex-arastocrats who are on the scene and you have people like Ebert saying,
在法国西部正在进行的政策，远离巴黎，但对于巴黎贫民窟的无套裤汉、那些正在挨饿的穷人来说，他们的怀疑、他们的仇恨，正被雅克·埃贝尔这样的人、这些煽动性的记者所放大。即使是这种灭绝政策也被认为是不够的。如果你是巴黎的一个激进分子，本质上旺代发生的事情太遥远了。你并没有真正掌握它。你从来没去过那里。你并不真正知道那里发生了什么。你知道的是，还有王室成员活着，现场还有前贵族，你有像埃贝尔这样的人说，
these guys are conspiring against you. And so a mood of mingled panic and hatred is motivating the enragee that the son-culot to demand the most extreme penalties against them, against these aristocrats. They're demanding that every aristocrat in France be hunted down, be branded, be chained in groups of six and be used by the army on the Vonde as human shields. And obviously, they want Marianne Winette shaved by the national razor, which is Ebert's phrase for a guillotining. And for them, this is the priority. And Ebert is shameless in kind of whipping it up. But just to say about Abert, I mean, his role in all this, he's not just an agitator. He does also have direct political agency. Listeners to our previous episode may remember that on the 5th of September, a demonstration
这些人正在密谋反对你们。因此，一种恐慌和仇恨交织的情绪促使激进分子、无套裤汉要求对他们、对这些贵族采取最极端的惩罚。他们要求追捕法国的每一位贵族，给他们打上烙印，六人一组锁在一起，并被旺代的军队用作人盾。显然，他们希望玛丽·安托瓦内特被“国家剃刀”剃头，这是埃贝尔对断头台的称呼。对他们来说，这是当务之急。埃贝尔在煽动方面是厚颜无耻的。但关于埃贝尔，我的意思是，他在这一切中的角色，他不仅仅是一个煽动者。他确实也有直接的政治行动力。我们上一集的听众可能还记得，9月5日，一场示威
had marched on the National Convention. And this was the march and the occupation of the convention that had inspired Barreire to stand up and say that terror should be the order of the day. And the leader of that demonstration, the guy who had led the enraget into the national convention, was a man called Gaspar Schomett. And he is not just a close friend and ally of Ebert, but his immediate superior in the Paris Commune. And the Paris Commune is basically the municipal government of the city.
游行到了国民公会。正是这次游行和对公会的占领激励了巴雷尔站起来说，恐怖应该是当务之急。那次示威的领导者，那个带领激进分子进入国民公会的人，是一个叫加斯帕尔·肖梅特的人。他不仅是埃贝尔的密友和盟友，还是他在巴黎公社的直接上级。而巴黎公社基本上是该市的市政政府。
And both men have official ranks in the commune. They rank as Procuror de la Commune. And this means that they are essentially the chief legal and administrative officers in Paris. And this is why Chomet had been able to play the prominent role that he did in the events of the 4th and 5th of September. And it is also why Ebert has been in a position to do much more than merely abuse the royal family in print. Because as a procureur, he has the prisoners in the temple under his direct charge. And even though Marie Antoinette has been transferred to the conciergerie, which means that she has now passed out of his authority, Ebert does still retain responsibility for the remaining three prisoners. So just to remind listeners who these remaining three prisoners are, there's Madame Elizabeth, the younger sister of Louis X.
两人在公社都有正式职位。他们的职位是公社检察官。这意味着他们本质上是巴黎的首席法律和行政官员。这就是为什么肖梅特能够在9月4日和5日的事件中发挥重要作用。这也是为什么埃贝尔能够做到的不仅仅是在报纸上辱骂王室。因为作为检察官，他直接负责圣殿塔的囚犯。尽管玛丽·安托瓦内特已被转移到古监狱，这意味着她现在已经脱离了他的管辖，但埃贝尔仍然对剩下的三名囚犯负有责任。所以提醒一下听众这剩下的三名囚犯是谁，有路易十六的妹妹伊丽莎白夫人。
There is Marie-Therese Charlotte, 14 years old, the daughter of the ex-Louis X Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette. And then there is her younger brother, only eight years old, who is to royalists Louis XVIth and to revolutionaries, Louis Chal Cappay. And this is the little boy who, on the night of the 3rd of July, had been forcibly removed from Mary Antoinette, his weeping mother, led down the spiral staircase and placed in a cell of his own. And the person who had given the orders for this to be done was a bear. And he did it for two reasons, didn't he?
有14岁的玛丽-泰蕾兹·夏洛特，她是前路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特的女儿。然后是她年仅八岁的弟弟，对于保皇党来说他是路易十七，对于革命者来说他是路易·夏尔·卡佩。这就是那个在7月3日晚上被强行从他哭泣的母亲玛丽·安托瓦内特身边带走，被带下螺旋楼梯并关进自己牢房的小男孩。下达这个命令的人是埃贝尔。他这样做有两个原因，不是吗？
First of all, he's hoping that they will get the boy to talk, that they can get testimony from the boy. The boy will inadvertently say things that they can use against his mother in a future trial. So that's thing number one. And then thing number two, of course, I mean, we've seen it through history. There are lots of little boys in medieval English and Scottish history who have become pawns or puppets or have become the focus for rebellions and uprisings. And he, Abert, is not wrong to think that what the boy that he calls the son of the she ape, you know, that he could be politically dangerous for the revolution. He could be a focus. for, you know, public uprisings and whatnot.
首先，他希望他们能让这个男孩开口，他们能从男孩那里得到证词。男孩会无意中说出一些他们可以在未来的审判中用来对付他母亲的话。所以这是第一点。然后是第二点，当然，我的意思是，我们在历史上已经看到了。在中世纪的英国和苏格兰历史上，有很多小男孩成为了棋子或傀儡，或者成为了叛乱和起义的焦点。而他，埃贝尔，认为他所称的“母猿之子”可能对革命具有政治危险性，这并没有错。他可能成为
Yes. Well, I mean, I think there is a parallel from English history that haunts the revolutionaries. But it's not a medieval king. It's Charles II who, Charles I first, his head had been chopped off. The monarchy had been abolished. But Charles II was always lurking on the scene and, of course, you have the restoration and the monarchy is restored. And I think that is the nightmare that haunts people like Ebert and actually all the
公众起义等等的焦点。
revolutionaries. And so the issue of what to do with this little boy is a very pressing political problem for the revolutionaries, because they can't really put him on trial, as they'd put his father on trial. I mean, he's just a little boy. Nor can they adopt the Richard the third approach. So to quote Deborah Cadbury, who's written a comprehensive and I have to say very harrowing biography of Louis Charles called the Lost King of France, a revolutionary led by high ideals, she writes, could not openly countenance the outright murder of a small boy.
是的。好吧，我的意思是，我认为英国历史上有一个困扰革命者的平行案例。但那不是中世纪的国王。而是查理二世，查理一世的头被砍掉了。君主制被废除了。但查理二世总是潜伏在现场，当然，后来有了复辟，君主制恢复了。我认为这就是困扰像埃贝尔这样的人，实际上是困扰所有
I mean, I think that's true. they can't behave like a kind of medieval usurper. So what to do? And Ebert has a solution, which he has agreed with Schomet, his immediate superior. So effectively, this now has kind of institutional approval. And the first kind of aspect of the policy that Ebert is introducing is to break the little boy, to brainwash him and to turn him against his parents and his heritage as a former dauphin. So Ebert says, the little whelp must lose the recollects.
革命者的噩梦。所以如何处理这个小男孩的问题对革命者来说是一个非常紧迫的政治问题，因为他们不能像审判他父亲那样审判他。我的意思是，他只是个小男孩。他们也不能采取理查三世的方法。正如黛博拉·卡德伯里所引用的，她写了一本全面且我必须说非常令人痛苦的关于路易·夏尔的传记，名为《法国失落的国王》，她写道，一个由崇高理想领导的革命，不能公开容忍对一个小男孩的直接谋杀。
of his royalty. And the plan is to install in the little boy, the tastes, the language, the educational standards of a son cul-lotte, and also to deny him all creature comforts, to keep him hungry, to deny him sleep. And if he should fail to survive the rigours of his new life, then, you know, what a shame. What a pity. You know, they won't have murdered him, but he will be removed from the scene if he just fades away. And so with these policies in mind, they appoint a new tutor for the erstwhile dauphin. And this is a guy called Antoine Simon. And he is a very different kind of tutor to the kind of tutor that the young dofins had had at Versailles. So Simons is a cobbler and he loathes the rich. He loves the revolution. And he had always, until this kind of bombshell
我的意思是，我认为这是真的。他们不能表现得像中世纪的篡位者。那么该怎么办？埃贝尔有一个解决方案，他已经与他的直接上级肖梅特达成了一致。所以实际上，这现在已经有了某种制度上的批准。埃贝尔引入的政策的第一个方面是摧毁这个小男孩，对他进行洗脑，让他反对他的父母和作为前王太子的遗产。所以埃贝尔说，“这个小崽子必须失去他作为皇室成员的记忆”。
appointment, being a complete failure in everything that he'd ever done. He can't even hack it as a cobbler. He's always kind of going bankrupt. He's always being evicted from his homes. He's not a very competent person at life, I think. Even his associates describing his manners as quite brutish. So he had a gruff, short way of talking and insolent gestures. He's also effectively illiterate. And so all of this makes him absolutely perfect from the point of view of Ebert. I have to say from the accounts you read, he comes over as an absolutely dreadful man. But on the other hand, you might say, well, a lot of the accounts we read are coloured with royalist propaganda. So there is that slight issue, isn't it? That hangs over all this.
计划是在这个小男孩身上灌输无套裤汉的品味、语言、教育标准，并拒绝给他任何物质享受，让他挨饿，拒绝让他睡觉。如果他没能从新生活的严酷中幸存下来，那么，你知道，真遗憾。真可惜。你知道，他们不会谋杀他，但如果他只是逐渐衰弱，他就会从现场消失。因此，考虑到这些政策，他们为这位前王太子任命了一位新导师。这是一个叫安托万·西蒙的人。他与凡尔赛宫年轻王太子所拥有的导师完全不同。西蒙是个鞋匠，他憎恨富人。他热爱革命。而且他一直以来，直到这次重磅
Not entirely royalist propaganda. So there are accounts as well from people who were there before and during the terror and survived the terror. Again, they might be party pre. But I think of the consensus of witnesses is pretty clear that Seymour is not Rory Stewart. Well, who is? He's not the kind of person you would necessarily appoint as a royal tutor. Roy Stewart, of course, tutored William and Harry. He did.
任命之前，在他所做的一切事情上都是个彻底的失败者。他甚至连鞋匠的工作都干不好。他总是破产。他总是被赶出家门。我认为他不是一个在生活中很有能力的人。甚至他的同事也形容他的举止相当粗鲁。所以他说话粗声粗气，举止傲慢。他实际上也是文盲。所以所有这些使他从埃贝尔的角度来看绝对完美。我必须说，从你读到的记录来看，他给人的印象是一个绝对可怕的人。但另一方面，你可能会说，好吧，我们读到的很多记录都带有保皇党的宣传色彩。所以确实存在那个轻微的问题，不是吗？这笼罩着这一切。
Yes. His methods, I suspect, are very different from Simons, because Simon is very much a practitioner of tough love with the accent very much on the tough. You say that. I mean, Rory Stewart went to Eaton. And there is perhaps something of Eaton in the 19th century about the education that Seymour gives the poor prince. So he's obliged to wait at table on Simor and his wife to polish their shoes. Basically, he's a kind of lackey. He's a fag, I guess. These young boys who have to serve their superiors at Eton. You could perhaps frame it back. I think it's slightly more brutal than that. I mean, certainly, it's a very different kind of education
并不完全是保皇党的宣传。所以也有来自那些在恐怖时期之前和期间并在恐怖时期幸存下来的人的记录。同样，他们可能带有党派偏见。但我认为证人的共识很清楚，西蒙不是罗里·斯图尔特。好吧，谁是呢？他不是那种你一定会任命为皇家导师的人。罗里·斯图尔特当然辅导过威廉和哈里。他确实辅导过。
to what the dofow would have had at Versailles. He is also, his appearance is transformed. So his blonde curls, which Mariantoinette had loved so much, they're shaved off. He's put in trousers, so no collot for him. And he's made to wear a red cap. As Simone is delighted and he cries out. Finally, cape, you are a son culotte.
是的。我怀疑他的方法与西蒙的非常不同，因为西蒙非常是一个“严厉的爱”的实践者，重点非常在于“严厉”。你这么说。我的意思是，罗里·斯图尔特去了伊顿公学。西蒙给这位可怜的王子提供的教育中，也许确实有19世纪伊顿公学的一些影子。所以他被迫在西蒙和他的妻子用餐时伺候，给他们擦鞋。基本上，他是一个仆人。我想他是一个苦力。这些在伊顿公学必须为上级服务的年轻男孩。你也许可以这样理解。我认为这比那稍微残酷一点。我的意思是，当然，这是一种非常不同的教育，
And Simon also, I mean, he's not completely useless. He does teach Louis Charles some things. So he teaches him how to sing revolutionary songs, teaches him how to curse and teaches him how to blaspheme. And Mary Torres, she hasn't actually witnessed this. So again, this is probably hearsay, but it does seem to be true. Simon taught him to swear dreadful oaths against God, his family and aristocrats. And we have the report of a commissioner who visits him.
与王太子在凡尔赛宫所受的教育不同。他的外表也被改变了。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特非常喜爱的金色卷发被剃掉了。他被穿上了长裤，所以没有短裤。他被迫戴上一顶红帽子。西蒙很高兴，他大喊道：“卡佩，你终于是一个无套裤汉了。”
You know, this is not a royalist. And he reports, I think, what's quite a shocking detail. Louis Schell heard his sister and art scraping chairs in the cell above him. He cried out, haven't those f*** women been guillotined yet? You assume that he's saying this because he thinks that it's going to please see more, who otherwise will probably beat him. But I mean, it's still quite an upsetting thing to say about your sister and your aunt, I think. And of course, there is no maths.
西蒙也不是完全没用。他确实教了路易·夏尔一些东西。所以他教他如何唱革命歌曲，教他如何咒骂，教他如何亵渎神灵。而玛丽·泰蕾兹，她实际上并没有亲眼目睹这一点。所以这可能又是道听途说，但这似乎确实是真的。西蒙教他用可怕的誓言咒骂上帝、他的家人和贵族。我们有一位探视他的专员的报告。
There's no geography. There's no history. Amarro to raise again, he was permitted only the most unspeakable books. And every effort was made to corrupt him. And what does this mean in practice? Well, I think, I mean, I think trying to answer this leads us to quite a dark place. And so anyone who is listening to this with children, I would. press the pause button. It also touches directly on the fate of Mariantoinette because you said that
你知道，这不是保皇党。他报告了一个我认为相当令人震惊的细节。路易·夏尔听到他的姐姐和姑姑在楼上的牢房里拖动椅子。他大喊道：“那些该死的女人还没被送上断头台吗？”你认为他这么说是为了取悦西蒙，否则西蒙可能会打他。但我的意思是，我认为这关于你的姐姐和姑姑来说仍然是一件相当令人不安的事情。当然，没有数学。
Abert is keen to get evidence that can be presented against her in a criminal case. You know, Abert is the guy more than anyone else who's been pursuing her and portraying her as this kind of monstrous sexual deviant. A woman who has incestuous tastes. Listeners can probably imagine what it is that Abert is trying to extract from her son. So charges are officially laid before. Marie Antoinette, the widow Capet, she's termed on the 3rd of October, 1793, and on the 14th of October, she is summoned before the Revolutionary Tribunal to answer them. And initially, there had been multitudes of allegations. You can imagine, you know, all the things that revolutionaries might bring against Mariannezzanette, but ultimately they've been boiled down
没有地理。没有历史。玛丽·泰蕾兹再次提到，他只被允许阅读最不堪入目的书籍。人们尽了一切努力来腐蚀他。这在实践中意味着什么？好吧，我认为，试图回答这个问题会把我们带到一个相当黑暗的地方。所以任何带着孩子听这个的人，我建议按下暂停键。这也直接触及了玛丽·安托瓦内特的命运，因为你说过
to three charges. These are, firstly, that she had dilapidated the French finances in a terrible way. And Mariantoinette responds to this by acknowledging that perhaps she had spent more than was entirely wise on the petty trianour. She has this brilliant phrase, I was dragged into expenses little by little. We're all familiar with that. But the more grotesque claims, essentially that she'd been so extravagant that she'd bankrupt into the French state, she repudiates a tone of great indignation. And the problem for her prosecutors are that there is no evidence for this. And the reason there's no evidence for it is that, you know, the evidence doesn't exist because Marie Antoinette hadn't bankrupted the French state. It was supporting the American tax rebels that had done that. They also
埃贝尔热衷于获得可以在刑事案件中对她不利的证据。你知道，埃贝尔是比任何人都更追求她并将她描绘成这种怪物般的性变态的人。一个有乱伦嗜好的女人。听众可能可以想象埃贝尔试图从她儿子那里提取什么。所以指控被正式提交给玛丽·安托瓦内特，卡佩遗孀，她在1793年10月3日被这样称呼，10月14日，她被传唤到革命法庭回答这些指控。最初，有大量的指控。你可以想象，你知道，革命者可能对玛丽·安托瓦内特提出的所有事情，但最终它们被归结为
charge her with betraying national secrets to France's enemies. And here, she was definitely guilty. She had definitely done that. So she was guilty of treason, I think, by the standards of the court. No question. She is talking to the Austrians all through, is it 1792? Absolutely no question that on the, you know, when it comes to the sort of national security angle, Marie Antoine had encouraged her Austrian relatives to march on Paris. And have they got to Varenne? Remember who did the episode about the flight to Varenne? If they'd got to Varenne, if they'd got out, and there's an episode that people often ask about and they say, gosh, what would have happened?
三项指控。首先，她以一种可怕的方式挥霍了法国的财政。玛丽·安托瓦内特对此回应说，她承认在小特里亚农宫的开销可能比完全明智的要多。她有一句精彩的话，“我一点一点地被拖入了开销中”。我们都熟悉这一点。但那些更荒诞的说法，本质上说她挥霍无度以至于让法国破产，她以极大的愤慨予以否认。检察官的问题在于没有证据。而没有证据的原因是，你知道，证据不存在，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特并没有让法国破产。是支持美国税务叛军导致了这一点。他们还
The result would have been a civil war in France. Yeah. So a lot of people would have died. I mean, a lot of people died anyway, frankly, but, you know, they'd have died differently. But Dominic, here is the thing. This accusation must have come from one of her husband's former ministers. And it is hearsay because there is no written evidence for it. I mean, actually, there is written evidence for it in the archives of various monarchies across Europe,
指控她向法国的敌人泄露国家机密。在这里，她绝对是有罪的。她确实那样做了。所以她犯了叛国罪，我认为，按照法庭的标准。毫无疑问。她在1792年全年都在与奥地利人交谈，不是吗？毫无疑问，在国家安全方面，玛丽·安托瓦内特鼓励她的奥地利亲戚向巴黎进军。他们到达瓦雷纳了吗？还记得谁做了关于逃往瓦雷纳的那一集吗？如果他们到达了瓦雷纳，如果他们逃出去了，人们经常问起那一集，他们说，天哪，会发生什么？
but the prosecutors don't have access to this material. So they kind of know that she's guilty, but they don't have any written proof. There's no smoking gun. There's the accusation that she had set a light civil war in various parts of the republic, and this is plainly ludicrous because she'd been in the temple when the revolt in the Vonday broke out, and everybody knew it. So actually, the evidence against her is a little thin. It's not as overwhelming as the prosecutors had hoped.
结果将是法国的内战。是的。所以很多人会死。我的意思是，坦率地说，很多人还是死了，但是，你知道，他们会以不同的方式死去。但多米尼克，问题在于。这个指控一定来自她丈夫的前任大臣之一。这是传闻，因为没有书面证据。我的意思是，实际上，在欧洲各国王室的档案中有书面证据，
And this is why, recognizing this, Abert drops a bombsha. And it's an additional corroborative statement proving the fact that Abert thinks Mary Antoinette deserves death. You know, it might seem as though it has sprung from the kind of the darkest, most depraved depths of his journalism. But it has been signed, and this is completely devastating for Marie Antoinette by her own son. And this statement alleges, and I quote, The young Capet was surprised by Seymour in an act of self-abuse. It describes how he had been taught to masturbate by his mother and his aunt. And worst of all, again, to quote this statement,
但检察官无法接触到这些材料。所以他们知道她有罪，但他们没有任何书面证明。没有确凿的证据。有指控称她在共和国的各个地区点燃了内战，这显然是荒谬的，因为当旺代起义爆发时，她一直被关在圣殿塔，每个人都知道这一点。所以实际上，对她的证据有点薄弱。并不像检察官希望的那样具有压倒性。
there is no doubt from what Capet's son has said that an act of incest was committed between mother and son. And Marianne Antoinette is so stunned by this that at first she doesn't know what to say. It just leaves her silent. She's so appalled by it. And then she's pressed by the president of the tribunal to answer the charge. And she says, if I did not respond, it was because it would be against nature for a mother to reply to such an accusation.
毫无疑问，从卡佩之子所说的话来看，母子之间确实发生了乱伦行为。玛丽·安托瓦内特对此感到震惊，起初她不知道该说什么。这让她陷入了沉默。她对此感到极其愤慨。随后，法庭主席催促她回答这一指控。她说，如果我没有回应，那是因为母亲对这样的指控做出回应是有悖天性的。
On this, I appeal to all the mothers who may be here, so the women who are watching in the gallery. And briefly, in the courtroom, astonishingly, there is a surge of sympathy for her. And that evening at dinner, Robespierre, who's been, you know, he's been informed what's happened, is furious. And he cries out that imbecile Ebert, enlivening her. her last moments with a public relations triumph. You know, to Robespierre, it seems a disaster. But actually, it's not, Abert knows his audience. And the news of what he is alleging sweet Paris, and they confirm all his supporters, all the Henri deignette, all the Sonsculot in their darkest
对此，我呼吁在场的所有母亲，以及在看台上观看的女性们。令人惊讶的是，法庭内短暂地涌现出对她的同情。那天晚上在晚餐时，罗伯斯庇尔得知了发生的事情，他非常愤怒。他大喊道，那个白痴埃贝尔，竟然用一场公关胜利来让她在最后时刻焕发光彩。对罗伯斯庇尔来说，这似乎是一场灾难。但实际上并非如此，埃贝尔了解他的听众。他所宣称的消息传遍了巴黎，并证实了他所有支持者、所有无套裤汉内心深处对她的怀疑。
suspicions of her. And sure enough, Mariannezzan, is convicted and the guilty verdict is brought in in the early hours of 16th of October. And as the verdict is read out, she shows not a trace of emotion. And she's returned to her cell at 4.30 in the morning. And there she writes letters to her two children. In these letters, she tells them, you know, basically forgive your enemies. Don't harbor grudges. Then at dawn, a guard comes and orders her to change out of her widow's weeds, her black dress, into a white dress. And the guard insists on watching her as she changes. And then at 10 o'clock, the executioner Henri Sanson arrives and he binds her hands very, very tightly behind her back, so tight that but it's painful for her, and then crops her hair, which by now is white and tangled.
果不其然，玛丽·安托瓦内特被判有罪，判决结果在10月16日凌晨宣布。当判决书宣读时，她没有流露出一丝情绪。她在凌晨4点30分被送回牢房。在那里，她给两个孩子写了信。在信中，她基本上告诉他们要宽恕敌人，不要怀恨在心。黎明时分，一名守卫进来，命令她脱掉丧服（那件黑色的裙子），换上一件白色的裙子。守卫坚持要看着她换衣服。上午10点，刽子手亨利·桑松到达，他把她的双手紧紧地反绑在身后，紧到让她感到疼痛，然后剪掉了她的头发，此时她的头发已经花白且凌乱不堪。
So very different to how she had looked at Versailles when her locks were being teased by Monsieur Leonor. And of course, the reason that Sansailles is doing that is to expose her neck. So at this point, Tom, she's 37 years old, so she's not an old woman by any means. But she must be, after all these long months of incarceration, plus the years of stress. She looks really aged. Yeah, she must cut a haggard figure. This brings her no sympathy in the court because it is a staple of pornographic literature that Ruiz, when they are uncovered, they immediately lose their looks.
这与她在凡尔赛宫时，由莱奥纳尔先生精心打理发型时的样子大相径庭。当然，桑松这样做是为了露出她的脖子。汤姆，此时她才37岁，绝不是个老妇人。但在经历了漫长的监禁和多年的压力之后，她一定显得非常苍老。是的，她看起来一定很憔悴。这并没有为她在法庭上赢得任何同情，因为色情文学中有一个惯例，即王后一旦被揭露，她们就会立刻失去美貌。
And so this seems to confirm Mariantoinette's reputation as a kind of character from Dangerous liaisons, something like that. All her hair has gone now. It's been cropped. And then she's led out into the courtyard. And she sees that she is to be taken to the scaffold, not in a carriage as her husband had been, but in a tumbril, like the common criminal that she is. in the opinion of the Revolutionary Tribunal. So she's going to be, you know, this Habsburg, this former Queen of France is going to be taken to her execution in a rubbish cart.
这似乎证实了玛丽·安托瓦内特作为《危险关系》中那种角色的名声。她的头发现在全没了，已经被剪掉了。随后她被带到庭院。她看到自己将被送往断头台，不是像她丈夫那样坐马车，而是像革命法庭眼中的普通罪犯一样，坐在一辆囚车里。所以，这位哈布斯堡家族的成员、这位前法国王后，将被一辆垃圾车送去处决。
And she's so shocked that she feels a violent need to relieve herself. It's at this point that the kind of the tight knots around her wrists are loosened so that she can relieve herself against the wall of the courtyard and everyone stands and watches her as she does so. And then she's put up into the tumbril. And it's not far to the Place de la Revolution, where she's going to be guillotined, But so many crowds have gathered to watch and to jeer her on her final journey that it takes her an hour to get there. And the painter David watches her go by and draws a very famous sketch.
她感到非常震惊，以至于有一种强烈的排泄需求。就在这时，她手腕上紧绷的绳结被松开，以便她能在庭院的墙边排泄，所有人都站在那里看着她。随后她被推上囚车。前往革命广场的路并不远，她将在那里被送上断头台，但由于聚集了太多人群观看并嘲笑她最后的旅程，她花了一个小时才到达。画家大卫看着她经过，并画了一幅非常著名的素描。
If you haven't seen it, you can Google it. It shows her kind of haggard, aged, her hair cropped, of course. But weirdly, a kind of enduring defiance. Her face is composed. Her chin is slightly raised. And everyone agrees that when she mounts the scaffold, She does it with a kind of impressive show of cool, which some attribute to courage and her enemies attribute to what they see as her habitual insolence. Well, can I just make a contrast here?
如果你还没看过，可以在谷歌上搜索一下。画中显示她显得憔悴、苍老，头发当然也被剪短了。但奇怪的是，她表现出一种持久的蔑视。她的面容平静，下巴微微抬起。每个人都同意，当她登上断头台时，她表现出一种令人印象深刻的冷静，有些人将其归功于勇气，而她的敌人则将其归功于他们眼中她一贯的傲慢。那么，我可以做一个对比吗？
A bear, the man who hounded her to her death. He will be mounting the scaffold in the next episode. And he cuts a very different figure. Ballin like a baby. Yeah, he dies like a dog. She's executed. Her head is exposed to the cheers of the crowd. And her clothes are stripped off her, according to an account published years later.
埃贝尔，那个将她逼向死路的男人。他将在下一集中登上断头台。他表现出的样子截然不同。像个婴儿一样哭泣。是的，他死得像条狗。她被处决了。她的头被展示给欢呼的人群看。据多年后发表的一份记录称，她的衣服被剥了下来。
so may not be entirely reliable, but it has a smack of truth. Her clothes are sent to hospital where they are to be worn by women who are never to know whose clothes they had once been. And of course, her body is dumped in a porpoise grave. And to lots of patriots, with the death of Marianne, perhaps even more than with the death of a husband, it seems that a new world has been born. And so a pamphlet is published shortly after her execution, which expresses this in the most exulting terms. Frenchmen, Republicans, you have purged the earth. of a monster who was its abomination. And on one level, this is obviously a massive exaggeration because purely on the symbolic level, of course, it was the death of Louis XVI, but had been
所以这可能并不完全可靠，但听起来有几分真实。她的衣服被送到医院，供那些永远不会知道这些衣服曾经属于谁的妇女们穿。当然，她的尸体被扔进了一个乱葬岗。对于许多爱国者来说，玛丽的死，甚至比她丈夫的死更让他们觉得一个新世界诞生了。因此，在她处决后不久，一本小册子出版了，用最狂喜的词汇表达了这一点。法国人，共和党人，你们已经从地球上清除了一个令人憎恶的怪物。从某种层面上看，这显然是巨大的夸张，因为纯粹从象征意义上讲，路易十六的死才是关键时刻。
the key moment. And you can see this in the way that Robespierre responds to Marie Antoinette's execution. So when Louis XVI had been taken to the guillotine, Robespier had been in his room in the House of the DuPlae, and he had solemnly turned his back on Louis's carriage as it had rumbled past. Marantranet, he pays no attention to it at all. It's a nothing event. him. Well, politically, it doesn't have that much significance, does it? I mean, doesn't change the balance of power in the convention. Marantir at this point has no political power. She's a leftover from a bygone age. Absolutely. And as you said, for Rosfeyer, it's all about the Gironin. And actually, their trial is going to begin eight days after Marie Antoinette has been guillotined. I mean,
你可以从罗伯斯庇尔对玛丽·安托瓦内特处决的反应中看出这一点。当路易十六被送往断头台时，罗伯斯庇尔一直待在杜普莱家的房间里，当路易的马车隆隆驶过时，他庄重地背过身去。对于玛丽·安托瓦内特，他根本没有理会。对他来说，这是一件无关紧要的事。从政治上讲，这并没有太大的意义，不是吗？我的意思是，这并没有改变国民公会中的权力平衡。玛丽·安托瓦内特此时没有任何政治权力。她是一个过时时代的遗物。绝对是这样。正如你所说，对罗伯斯庇尔来说，一切都是关于吉伦特派。实际上，他们的审判将在玛丽·安托瓦内特被送上断头台八天后开始。我的意思是，
that's the focus of all Ross Pierre's energies. And actually, even in the Vonday by this point, where royalism really had presented a serious threat to the revolution, the tide of war is at last starting to turn in favor of the revolution. So on the 17th of October, which is one day after Marie Antoinette's execution, Republican forces meet with the main Bondayan army at Cholet, and they win a massive victory there. So this is just south of the river. L'Ire. Just to give a kind of a quick synopsis of what happens in the months after in the Vonday. In December, the Vondayans are beaten again at Le Mans. There's kind of massive street fighting. The battle basically takes place in the town itself. And so huge numbers of civilians get
那是罗伯斯庇尔所有精力的焦点。实际上，即使是在此时的旺代地区，保皇党确实对革命构成了严重威胁，但战争的局势终于开始向有利于革命的方向转变。因此，在10月17日，也就是玛丽·安托瓦内特被处决后的第二天，共和军在绍莱与旺代主力军相遇，并取得了巨大的胜利。这就在卢瓦尔河南岸。简单概述一下旺代地区之后几个月发生的事情。12月，旺代人在勒芒再次被击败。那里发生了大规模的巷战。战斗基本上是在城镇内进行的。因此，大量的平民也遭到
slaughtered as well, an absolute kind of bloodbath. And then there's a final defeat for the Bondi enforces on the 23rd of December, and this effectively marks the end of the rebellion. So that basically is the royalist threat to the revolution out of the way. But in Paris, royalists do continue to be sent to the guillotine, but increasing, the more that they get sent to the guillotine, the less even the kind of, you know, the most anti-royalists among the sonculot feel that, you know, they're no real threat at all. So just to give the names of some of those royalists who are sent to the guillotine. Elimte de Guzhe, the famous feminist, author of the Declaration of the Rights of Women and the Female Citizen.
屠杀，简直是一场血洗。随后，旺代军队在12月23日遭遇了最终的失败，这实际上标志着叛乱的结束。所以，保皇党对革命的威胁基本上被消除了。但在巴黎，保皇党人继续被送上断头台，但越来越多的人被送上断头台，即使是无套裤汉中最反保皇党的人也觉得，他们根本构不成真正的威胁。列举一些被送上断头台的保皇党人的名字。奥兰普·德·古热，著名的女权主义者，《女权与女公民宣言》的作者。
We did an episode on her. Her declaration of the rights of women was a kind of celebrated plea for equal rights, and she had the famous and ironic slogan, woman has the right to climb onto the scaffold. She must equally have the right to climb onto the tribunal. And this declaration of the rights of women had been dedicated to Marianne Antoinette. Elimte de Guz had also publicly opposed the execution of Louis XVIth and the turn of the Revolution to Terror, So that was enough to condemn her. So she never climbed the tribunal, but on the 3rd of November, she did climb the scaffold. And that was the end of her. Then three days later on the 6th of November, Dominic, surely for you, the greatest moment in the entire French Revolution, Philippe Galilei goes to the guillotine.
我们做过一期关于她的节目。她的《女权宣言》是对平等权利的一种著名呼吁，她有一句著名且讽刺的口号：女性有权登上断头台，就必须同样有权登上法庭。这份《女权宣言》是献给玛丽·安托瓦内特的。奥兰普·德·古热还公开反对处决路易十六以及革命转向恐怖统治，所以这足以判处她死刑。因此，她从未登上法庭，但在11月3日，她确实登上了断头台。那是她的结局。三天后的11月6日，多米尼克，对你来说这绝对是整个法国大革命中最伟大的时刻，菲利普·加利特被送上了断头台。
And to give him credit, he has dressed very elegant before it. I kind of like that in a prisoner. And he's supposed to have quipped that he had known better days. So I quite like that as well. So he dies well. And I think the saddest death and the one that is felt to be most pathetic, really. Even the tricketers feel a bit bad about this is Madame Elizabeth, the younger sister of Louis XVI. She's executed on the 10th of May 1794.
说句公道话，他在上断头台前穿得非常优雅。我有点喜欢囚犯这样。据说他打趣说他曾有过更好的日子。所以我很喜欢这一点。所以他死得很好。我认为最悲伤、最令人感到可怜的死亡，即使是那些行刑者也对此感到有些难过，那就是路易十六的妹妹伊丽莎白夫人。她于1794年5月10日被处决。
For no good reason. For no good reason at all. She's part of a kind of batch of 24 prisoners who are being executed en masse. And they're executed in ascending order of rank. And so she is the very last person to be executed. So she has to sit there watching all the other prisons being killed. And I think, you know, even people on the street feel this is a bit much. And actually, Robespierre, he's blamed for this, even though he hadn't wanted Madame Elizabeth to be executed.
毫无理由。完全没有理由。她是那批被集体处决的24名囚犯之一。他们按等级升序被处决。所以她是最后一个被处决的人。她不得不坐在那里看着所有其他囚犯被杀。我想，即使是街上的人也觉得这太过分了。实际上，罗伯斯庇尔因此受到了指责，尽管他并不想处决伊丽莎白夫人。
And he complains about it the next day to Barre and says, you see, it is always me. I'm always being blamed for it. I'm the real victim in all this. He's the real victim, yeah. And by this point, you know, the reason that people feel that Madame Elizabeth shouldn't really be executed is because the job has been done. You know, there is no conceivable comeback for the Anciar regime now. in France. And I think that Abert, by hunting
第二天他向巴雷尔抱怨说，你看，总是怪我。我总是因此受到指责。我是这一切中真正的受害者。他是真正的受害者，是的。到这个时候，人们觉得伊丽莎白夫人不应该被处决的原因是，工作已经完成了。你知道，在法国，旧制度现在已经没有任何卷土重来的可能了。我认为埃贝尔通过追捕
Marie Antoinette to her death, and by casting her at her trial as someone haunting the darkest fantasies of the Marquis de Sard, he had actually known what he was doing, despite Rospy, I think, that it was mad behaviour, because what it did
玛丽·安托瓦内特直到她死，并在审判中将她描绘成一个困扰萨德侯爵最黑暗幻想的人，他实际上知道自己在做什么，尽管罗伯斯庇尔认为这是疯狂的行为，因为他所做的是
was to brand the French monarchy as something monstrous, as something contemptible as well, something grotesque. And the mud of that does stick. And it means, you know, in the long run, I think it dooms the French monarchy. There are attempts to bring it back, but it never really succeeds. I think it has been made to seem kind of ludicrous. I'm not sure I agree with that, actually.
将法国君主制打上怪异、卑劣以及荒诞的烙印。这种污名确实挥之不去。这意味着，从长远来看，我认为它注定了法国君主制的灭亡。虽然有尝试恢复它，但从未真正成功。我认为它已经被弄得看起来很荒谬。实际上，我不确定我是否同意这一点。
French monarchy returned in 1815, and it lasted until 1848. I mean, that's 33 years. That's quite a long time. I think the foundations are rotten through. I know it's a different beast, but I don't think it's inconceivable that France could have a monarchy today. I mean, 33 years is a, you know, someone's lifetime. I think it's inconceivable. I think it destroys the mystique that ultimately a monarchy in the 19th century required.
法国君主制在1815年回归，一直持续到1848年。我的意思是，那是33年。那是一段很长的时间。我认为其根基已经彻底腐烂了。我知道这是另一回事，但我不认为法国今天拥有君主制是不可想象的。我的意思是，33年是一个人的生命周期。我认为这是不可想象的。我认为它摧毁了19世纪君主制最终所需要的神秘感。
You know, even posing as citizen kings doesn't really help the years of it. The magic of it is gone. And that's basically what Burke was saying as well. I think that that Abeir trashes it so completely that ultimately the filth can't be cleaned away. And not only that, he has also played his part in, so if he's killed the French monarchy off, he's also played the part in another literal death. And this isn't an execution before the gaze of the people, but one that is silent and squalid and veiled from every human eye, actually. And this is a terrible story.
你知道，即使假装成公民国王也无济于事。它的魔力已经消失了。这基本上也是伯克所说的。我认为埃贝尔彻底摧毁了它，以至于最终污垢无法被清除。不仅如此，他还参与了另一场字面意义上的死亡。这不是在人民注视下的处决，而是一场沉默、肮脏且对所有人隐瞒的死亡。这是一个可怕的故事。
This is the darkest and one of the saddest stories in the whole revolution, I think. So on the 19th of January 1794, the Seymour, the cobbler and his wife, are dismissed from the temple. They are no longer the tutor of the former Dofant. And two days later, the by now eight-year-old Louis-Chal Capet is walled up in the temple. that room where his father had been when he was taken to his execution. He's walled up in the corner of it. So he's kind of imprisoned in effectively what is now a very small cell. It has no natural light.
我认为这是整个革命中最黑暗、最悲伤的故事之一。1794年1月19日，鞋匠西蒙和他的妻子被从圣殿塔解雇。他们不再是前王储的导师。两天后，当时八岁的路易-夏尔·卡佩被关在圣殿塔里。那是他父亲被带去处决时所在的房间。他被关在房间的角落里。所以他实际上被囚禁在一个现在非常小的牢房里。那里没有自然光。
There's no windows. And in fact, there is only a single grill. That's the only kind of access point through which meals can be handed. These meals are deliberately not very filling. They're basically a couple of bowls of soup a day with a husk of bread, perhaps a lump of kind of gristle and neat. No lantern is allowed after dusk, so he spends hours and hours in pitch darkness.
没有窗户。事实上，只有一个单一的格栅。那是唯一可以递送食物的入口。这些食物故意做得不怎么管饱。基本上每天只有几碗汤和一块面包皮，可能还有一块软骨和肉。日落后不允许使用灯笼，所以他在漆黑中度过了漫长的时光。
He's allowed no change of clothes. So he is wearing the same clothes day after day, month after month that he was wearing when he was first immured in this cell. And there are no toilet facilities. So people can imagine how, as the months go by, how squalid his living conditions are. And in fact, the room, become so filled with ferman that there were occasions where the poor boy would not eat his meals
他不被允许更换衣服。所以他日复一日、月复一月地穿着他最初被关进这个牢房时穿的衣服。而且没有厕所设施。所以人们可以想象，随着时间的推移，他的生活条件有多么肮脏。事实上，房间里充满了害虫，以至于有几次这个可怜的孩子甚至不吃他的饭菜，
because the food would attract the vermin. The vermin would then leave him alone and allow him to snatch a few hours' sleep. And a guard notices this and says, well, why aren't you eating the food? And the boy replied, well, what would you do, my friend? I want to die. And so in due course he does. Because he is kept in the cell for six months and then he's released, but he never really recovers from the kind of horrific experience of his solitary confinement. For those six months, he had been covered in his own excrement, his own waist, his clothes kind of rotting away on his body. And when he comes out, he is so covered in soaws and postules and he's got tumors and parasites. and his only joy really is the tame birds that he keeps his pets.
因为食物会吸引害虫。害虫随后会离开他，让他能抢到几个小时的睡眠。一名守卫注意到这一点并问，你为什么不吃东西？孩子回答说，我的朋友，你会怎么做？我想死。所以他最终确实死了。因为他被关在牢房里六个月，然后被释放，但他从未从那种可怕的单独监禁经历中真正恢复过来。在那六个月里，他身上沾满了自己的排泄物，衣服在他身上腐烂。当他出来时，他浑身长满了疮和脓疱，还有肿瘤和寄生虫。他唯一的快乐其实是他当作宠物的驯养鸟儿。
And there's kind of bitter irony there because Robespierre, as a small boy, had kept birds as pets. And Robespier had actually paid a visit to the temple. Very Robespierre, he paused and started looking at the bookcase. But he only speaks to Maritare's. He doesn't go and investigate what is happening to this boy. Perhaps if he'd seen him and seen him with his birds, he might have been a little spark a fellow feeling, I don't know.
这其中有一种苦涩的讽刺，因为罗伯斯庇尔小时候也养过鸟。罗伯斯庇尔实际上曾去过圣殿塔。非常罗伯斯庇尔，他停下来开始看书架。但他只和玛丽·安托瓦内特说话。他没有去调查这个孩子身上发生了什么。也许如果他见过他，看到他和他的鸟在一起，他可能会产生一点同情心，我不知道。
Louis Charles never, never recovers. he fades away and on the 7th of June 1795 so by this point of course the terror is over that's why he's been released he starts crying calling for his mother and he still doesn't know that marianternet has been sent to the guillotine and then the following day he starts struggling to breathe and then he dies and i suppose you could say that from beyond the grave because by this point ebert himself is dead that abe's work is done the boy was 10 years old 10 years old when he dies yeah so nowhere of Louis XVIth and Marie Antoinette will return to Versailles. Louis the 17th will never play the part of Charles II.
路易-夏尔从未恢复过来。他逐渐衰弱，1795年6月7日，此时恐怖统治当然已经结束，这就是他被释放的原因，他开始哭泣，呼唤他的母亲，他仍然不知道玛丽·安托瓦内特已经被送上了断头台。第二天，他开始呼吸困难，然后就死了。我想你可以说，因为埃贝尔本人此时已经死了，埃贝尔的工作已经完成了。这个孩子死时才10岁，10岁。是的，所以路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特的后代再也不会回到凡尔赛宫了。路易十七永远不会扮演查理二世的角色。
He will not be restored to the throne. And I think that the monarchy essentially, as it had been constituted for centuries and centuries of centuries, has perished more surely amid the darkness of that cell than it had done on the scaffold. But Dominic, we've been saying how Ebert is going to be getting into trouble. So what about him? And what about Rovst-Pierre? what's been happening to them and to the course of the revolution, while poor Louis Charles Capet has been fading away in the darkness of the temple.
他不会恢复王位。我认为君主制本质上，正如几个世纪以来所构成的那样，在那个牢房的黑暗中比在断头台上灭亡得更彻底。但是多米尼克，我们一直在说埃贝尔会惹上麻烦。那么他呢？罗伯斯庇尔呢？当可怜的路易-夏尔·卡佩在圣殿塔的黑暗中逐渐衰弱时，他们和革命的进程发生了什么？
And those questions we are going to be answering, aren't we, in our next episode? Completely. So next episode is a very, very dramatic one. It is the showdown between Robespair and Dantong, a jewel for the ages, a jewel that's become a symbol of extremism versus moderation. And we are approaching, of course, the climax of the reign of terror. So a lot of guillotining, a lot of political drama, a lot of excitement to come. Now, if you want to listen to that episode right away and indeed the next two episodes on the
这些问题我们将在下一集中回答，不是吗？完全正确。所以下一集是非常非常戏剧性的一集。这是罗伯斯庇尔和丹东之间的对决，一场跨时代的决斗，一场成为极端主义与温和派象征的决斗。当然，我们正在接近恐怖统治的高潮。所以会有很多断头台处决，很多政治戏剧，很多令人兴奋的内容。现在，如果你想立刻收听那一集，以及接下来的两集关于
Revolution's War on Christianity and the fall of Rob Speer that brings the terror to an end, you can actually listen to those right away, but only if you're a member of the Rest is History Club. And if you want to join the Rest Is History Club, there is brilliant bombshell news. We now have a website never before mentioned on the show. It's the rest is history.com. And also for the first time in human history, we are offering a range of supplementary benefits. Wow.
革命对基督教的战争以及导致恐怖统治结束的罗伯斯庇尔的倒台，你其实可以立刻收听，但前提是你必须是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员。如果你想加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，有一个绝妙的重磅新闻。我们现在有一个节目中从未提及的网站。它是therestishistory.com。而且，人类历史上第一次，我们提供了一系列补充福利。哇。
They come along with ad-free listening. Unreal. And early access and all these incredible things. Absolutely incredible. So, merci, Tom, and au-voir. Bye, everybody. Happy a unto. The great game,
它们伴随着无广告收听。太不可思议了。还有提前访问权和所有这些令人难以置信的事情。绝对令人难以置信。所以，谢谢你，汤姆，再见。再见，大家。祝大家愉快。伟大的博弈，
strategic struggle between Britain and Russia. We assess a prime minister. with high confidence it was Russian. Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people. Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, do you want to play or not? You're the Prime Minister.
英国和俄罗斯之间的战略斗争。我们评估了一位首相。有高度信心认为是俄罗斯人。让俄罗斯人负责就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫的那个人在玩弄，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩还是不想玩？你是首相。
You've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context. All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today. And disseminated into an operation order, or fragom. A fraga that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Goldhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off?
你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。所有相关的背景今天都将构建为一个框架。并分发到作战命令或碎片命令中。一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的碎片命令。是的。Goldhanger的新作。谁能做到这一点？
You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuffie. An audio drama journey like no other. Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous geopolitical action thriller. We have two-time's friendly key. Where Britain plays its strongest hand. against its strongest foe. Bear hunt.
你是我的士兵，是吗？汤姆·麦克达菲中士。一段独一无二的音频剧旅程。像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。被设计为一部技术严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有两次友好的关键。英国在那里打出了最强的一手牌。对抗它最强大的敌人。猎熊。
Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。